i assure you representative soloway
after you left last week we didn't have
any more fun
[Music]
okay
if you have a pink card for the next
hearing please bring it up
if you have any other colored cards you
welcome to the best committee in the
house of representatives
we've got a few bills that we're going
to do hearings on today as well as exec
and depending on how the time flows we
have bills that just have to be exact
only and we will work them in
the chair recognizes
senate apprentice
sent senate bill 335 and act relative to
collaborative
pharmacy practices agreements and
we're dedicating this morning to senate
apprentice because we have a whole
series of wonderful things and it just
seemed right not to have you run back
and forth but just stay with us
welcome
thank you very much thank you very much
for that warm welcome and it is great to
be with you all this morning here at
you know house health human services and
elderly affairs i appreciate the way you
scheduled the time and um but be clear i
would have run back and forth to be here
let's be clear there will be an ask from
yes chair person so um so good morning i
am here to introduce um 335 and this is
relative to collaborative
practice agreements and so for the
record my name is sue prentiss i'm a
state senator from district five i cover
nine communities in the beautiful
connecticut river valley of new
hampshire
and i specifically hail from west
lebanon
the new hampshire health systems
pharmacists and dartmouth-hitchcock
medical center in
forward senate bill 335 and this is
making one simple change to a statute
that governs collaborative practice
collaborative practice agreements held
between a pharmacist and a prescribing
provider
senate bill 335 is removing an
unnecessary patient action step from
this mode of healthcare delivery i have
marilyn hill here with me this morning
who is the ambulatory pharmacy manager
at dh
she's here to testify on behalf of the
new new hampshire
health system pharmacists in favor of
the bill and she'll be able to answer
any more technical questions that you
does not undermine consent in any way
between patients and their providers and
marilyn hill will help to clarify that
as we move forward so um that's i am
done with my introduction i'm happy to
answer any questions or
turn to some of my technical experts in
the room to assist chair pearson and
members of the committee thank you any
questions of the senator from the
thank you you're welcome thank you don't
go far
i'll be right here chair recognizes
marilyn hill i was going to say if you
can walk up here but you've already been
good morning jeremy peterson and the
members of the committee my name is
marilyn hill and the ambulatory farms a
couple different things
a beautiful infographic that one of my
colleagues made and then we also have an
example of a collaborative practice
agreement
before we get started i just want to
unpack when we think of pharmacy
practice you usually imagine getting
your medication in a bag from the
pharmacy this is separate and distinct
from that because this allows
pharmacists to work in collaboration
with those prescribing providers to use
their doctor degree to manage chronic
disease states
this isn't tied to the dispensing
activities at all it can happen in any
setting of health care
but it is in close collaboration with
that prescribing provider so
the current statute
has
directions on how to actually go about
putting this together there are about 35
different collaborative practice
agreements in the state right now
serving hundreds to thousands of
patients
it is a technical legal document that
has clinical information um that is
signed by all the prescribing providers
by the pharmacist it's reviews by the
board of pharmacy and the statute
currently requires the patient to also
sign this big intimidating package so
this bill is to just strike that line
from statute it does not affect informed
consent law elsewhere in statute i'm not
a lawyer so i don't know exactly where
that is but i know it exists um and this
does not in any way affect the patient's
choice of where to send their
prescriptions when to participate in the
health care system or anything of that
nature so i'd love to turn it over to
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
just looking at this wonderful chart
it looks like it the pharmacist takes on
a lot more responsibility and i wanted
to know if this was going to overburden
pharmacists
or if it actually makes their job easier
that's a wonderful and very thoughtful
question i appreciate that um the the
law the amendment sorry the statute
change in front of you does not at all
affect the scope of practice currently
so it will remain unchanged um the
question in terms of like burden i can't
exactly speak to open up an area of
practice known as ambulatory care
that has been present in states across
the country for several decades it's
pretty new to us in new hampshire
but it is a really attractive place for
new practitioners to practice and the
collaborative practice agreements
enables that to happen
so
the burden is not touched by this
statute change
but it is a cool place to practice
follow-up
thank you
um
does does this require a pharmacist to
get any more certifications or do they
have to do they have to get
more education in how they deal with
patients i just a question yeah great
thank you um
there is in the rules i believe it's in
the rules basically in the application
that's submitted to the board of
pharmacy the pharmacist is required to
state their level of education and it's
built into the hearing process before
the board to determine if the pharmacist
is has the education and background
required to do the work that is outlined
in the in the agreement
so that's by the board of pharmacy i
would say
representative gay
thank you thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question how does the
the
results of blood tests things like that
that would drive the change in the
prescription
a very operational question i am happy
to clarify and it kind of depends on
what setting it's taking place in so i
can speak to my staff they're embedded
in primary care clinics working
alongside with the providers who refer
and sign this document so everything's
in our electronic medical record um if
things are crossing into different
phases of care that would be an
operational question for them to address
i can't speak to that because all of my
people are
in in the same place as the uh referring
provider it doesn't necessarily have to
be that way um and
yeah so i guess i can't answer that
fully follow-up
thank you
i'm not quite i'm sure you're answering
my question i'm just not following the
answer
are the pharmacists given the same
access to the testing
or whatever you're monitoring this
ongoing uh
chronic condition how do the pharmacists
get that information so they can make
changes to the prescription yes so um
the way my staff works they have the
same access to the electronic medical
record as everyone else in the clinic
does so if you're a nurse or an ma or a
physician who's going in to look at the
patient's chart the blood tests are
sitting there to review so um
yeah they have the same access as
everyone else i guess it's the answer to
your question for my team representative
soloway
uh thank you mr chairman uh welcome dr
hill it's nice to have you here and
thank you for taking my question it's
two-part question
different issues okay um in my limited
experience
pharmacists came in two flavors um
prescribing pharmacists and clinical
pharmacists uh dispensing pharmacists
and clinical pharmacists okay sure okay
um and the clinical pharmacists are the
ones who
check
the entire team for dosages drug
interaction effects and so forth and
they really operate as clinicians does
this
move
the role of the dis of the dispensing
pharmacist more in the direction of the
clinical pharmacist
the statute does not affect any piece of
the different scopes that you're
perceiving it it just removes the
signature required in the agreement that
currently exists in statute
it's just a piece of paperwork honestly
so it doesn't change anything about
practice besides we no longer need to
have the patient sign a piece of paper
keep that on file in case of audits and
like keep track of that okay your second
question
um does this change the role of um the
farm tech
no thank you
thank you
representative canark thank you i want
to make actually a point of information
for the committee
everything we just talked about is about
the collaborative practice agreement
statute this does not affect that the
collaborative practice agreement is
already in statute
all this does is it unburdens the
provider by saying you don't have to get
this separate signature
and the analogy if you look at the
handout she gave as you don't sign
something between your farm your pt and
your doc the point is
we're debating how this is structured
it's already in statute we should not be
debating that to save us time because
it's already in statute we should debate
the bill at hand
representative merchant is a co-sponsor
so there's something you're not supposed
to do but i'm going to call on you to do
something else
it's more a point of clarification than
asking a question by me
the point of clarification is the
collaborative practice the people that
do this work
are working in the clinic
they're not i want to be sure people
understand there's dispensing which is
going to be what you see today in cvs
walgreens and so forth that's not a
collaborative practice that's not where
it's occurring the collaborative
practice is like a physician assistant
working with a physician in the clinic
so therefore when you talk about the
workload and burden and so forth that is
not going to impact it because they're
not involved with the dispensing
function involved if you will helping
the physician with managing the therapy
on behalf of the patient it's more
informational than a question sir thank
you so in other words let's not
overthink this don't overthink it please
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
doctor for being here um i think a lot
of us are just trying to understand just
how big this is and taking out that step
um it seems like a great program are
there some parts that are reserved to
the practitioner like the initial
prescription of a continuous glucose
monitor and then that maintenance
happens um at the at the collaborative
pharmacy agreement
um that would depend on the specific
agreement between the practitioner and
the pharmacist so it certainly can be it
kind of varies depending on what
resources and level of comfort currently
exists based on the relationships they
have
um
yeah customizable thank you yep
representative woods
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question i just heard
clarification from what representative
merchant
said this does not really affect
the right aid pharmacist they don't have
collaborative agreements it's only in
the clinical setting
um i don't work for rite aid so i cannot
confirm or deny that um i know there's a
variety throughout the state i don't i
don't know if i don't think any
currently exist in that sphere but again
i can neither confirm nor deny that i'm
gonna go out on a limb and ask our
during my time on the board of pharmacy
there was no collaborative agreements
between what caller retail community
pharmacy and physicians offices and part
of that reason is if i may explain it
and somebody touched upon this in order
to do collaborative agreement you have
to have access to the medical record
because you have to understand where the
blood
levels are what's going on and so forth
that
access is because you work with inside
the clinic if you're working third party
outside of the clinic to have access to
that data is very problematic if not
impossible so therefore the barrier
between a community pharmacy involvement
with collaborative practice and a
physician prescribing if you will or a
nurse practitioner is almost
non-existent and during my time at the
board there was no
desire nor anything coming to the board
because of those obstacles everything we
saw before the board was definitely
based in a clinic working with a
prescribing provider
hand in hand if you will because of that
reason of having access to the data and
ex faces records
representative woods
thank you
uh thank you mr chef uh then if i
understand this correctly if that's the
situation
uh this signature that we're getting rid
of is actually redundant
because when you come to a clinic
you sign my understanding is you sign
a release for treatment
and that includes whatever the
staff does and if the pharmacist is part
of the staff
then it's already taken care of so
i have in my notes uh something that uh
best sergeant or lobbyist uh sent us all
patient has already given consent with
the pcp for care so it's redundant
so uh would anybody not like to ask
thank you for your testimony thank you
the
this concludes the hearing on senate
bill 335 and opens the exact session and
the chair turns to
representative merchant for a motion
i would happily make a motion ought to
pass
and i'll suck at that motion are you all
so happy very happy
thank you i want you to be happy
uh any further discussion
hearing none uh when one of the clerks
is ready please call the
roll this is a very busy committee we
representative land yes
representative mcmahon yeah
representative acton yes
representative gay
representative dolan yeah
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes
representative king yes
representative colfell
yes representative delemus
representative mckay
representative snow
oh absent yes
representative kenner yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes
representative
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes and representative query
yes and representative pearson yes
it is unanimous twenty to zero
now who asks me the question yes consent
no objections
and the blurb please written by
close the executive session on 335 we've
got uh several minutes before the next
bill is scheduled to be heard
uh so we can take out please senate bill
290 and i open the exact session because
we've already heard it at about twenty
past eight last week in the evening
and we were probably remember some of it
it was the relative to the practice of
auriculotherapy
ah yeah uh let's so fish out 290
oh come on this is going to be a lot of
fun
[Laughter]
everybody ready the chair recognizes
himself
to make the motion for interim study do
i have a second
second who said that merchant merchant
okay merchant
and i speak to that in that um
gosh
many of us remember in medicine when
there were doctors rns lpns and janitors
and over the years there have been
numbers of slots in between those
so the idea of training an individual up
to a certain level
certainly has merit
if the need is there and you need an lpn
you don't need to staff it with a nurse
practitioner that slot
so i'm convinced that there is a
possibility theoretically for
um
what was brought to us
my concern is that we want to make sure
that
individuals are adequately trained
i seem to recall that numbers of the
people advocating for this had already
been extremely well trained over what is
necessary
but there still seems to be the
possibility somebody could come in off
the street armed with five needles and
go to work and we're not happy with that
i don't think so by interim study i mean
let's bring the participants together
and thrash out something
that we could be in favor of at a later
date when it comes back to us so
with that any further discussion or
questions or what have you
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman i would just say
quickly that um
while the bill it seems to me what did
not adequately address accountability
and training and standards
we should remember that there's already
a statute that allows a certain group of
people to do this most basic
auricular therapy and that will continue
in your opinion then what is the
advantage to having the bill before us
is there anything it adds that isn't
yes representative shapiro i'm not sure
there is but um by sending it to interim
study we allow
the stakeholders to um
more adequately address how they would
expand what's being done now i think so
representative kanark
uh yes that's the thing i i think that
i'm very troubled by this expanding the
scope of practice but lessening the
amount of
uh education training and certification
with absolutely no accountability and
that just doesn't make any sense so i
agree with interim study if it's not the
other motion uh that kills it quicker
but either way i think interim study is
a perfectly fine option for this i think
interim study keeps us in the game right
where it's just killing it
yeah i know it doesn't so much
yeah
representative merchant
thank you mr chair
also um
as i said to a chair i missed last
tuesday uh which was kind of a long day
but i did go back and listen to the tape
or listen to the video not all of it but
a lot of it and what i found very
interesting with auriculotherapy
was those who advocated for it when they
talked about training
they didn't say they didn't want to have
training but the way the bill is written
it's only training for
sterile technique it's not training in a
regular therapy so i think there's a
need here to look at this through a
study committee to begin to understand
can we take the narda of which used for
detox and possibly expand those
individuals their scope or practice in
order to accommodate more things so i
think interim study will allow for that
process to unfold and to bring the
stakeholders together and talk about how
we can use this therapy modality in a
representative gay i can always think of
something
um
you mentioned you mentioned that some
people are already practicing this and
if i understood when they were
testifying that there are people who are
trained who are trained
uh was it in the military so they're
doing this but again they have training
i i totally agree with the idea of i.s
representative canark uh no the the ones
who testified such as dr nagle and
others are trained acupuncturists when
they are doing it the military has a
program but even that requires training
representative woods
thank you mr chair i think this issue of
certification is is is in fact a very
cogent issue
um
i'm just harking back to a suit that was
brought against myself
as chair of the state workers comp
advisory council
about doing imes
independent medical examinations
and we had charlens coming across the
border with quotes
certifications
to do such
it turns out there was 438 certifying
agencies in the u.s 130 of them in las
vegas
what could go wrong there could go wrong
there
[Music]
so i had a bill brought forward that
said to do imes you had to be board
certified in one of the 26 specialties
as identified by the american board of
medical specialties
so that raised a standard so you could
still do them
but there was a standard for which we
felt it should be acceptable
um
as such that passed and i was
subsequently sued by someone who did not
have a board certification
and uh ag's office gave me a call and
said what do you think and i told them
the reasoning and he said well we'll
work on this
and much to my
relief about six weeks later he said we
took care of it don't worry about it
so i think there is a legal issue here
as well
um and in the background would be
potentially
the same thing someone bringing a suit
of restraint of trade
but i think if we go through the process
and put it on a standard basis
and then looking at it from both sides
through is
that will be accomplished and that will
provide a track record um for those who
follow to say
you've done due diligence so i'm very
you're helping me write my blurb keep it
up guys
i also noticed down here under um
lowercase a has appropriate training in
clean needle technique
who says
no okay yeah who says you've had it and
what is it
i mean it begs the question
uh my wife and i are plowing through um
the early years of the tv show law and
order and in season 4 episode 21 the
exact
the exact issue of does not purport to
treat any disease disorder infirmity or
affliction came up
as the issue
because they were able to
find and prove
that the person who was doing some
something
wasn't just saying
i can't guarantee this will cure you but
i do believe it won't hurt you
sometimes
but it shaded into what a reasonable
person would adhere
as
this is a treatment for a disease
so ripped from the headlines huh
on that issue of does not purport to
treat any disease disorder infirmity or
affliction do we just want to leave that
hanging as such or might that be better
okay i'm just writing the blurb and
we've got a few minutes
can i call the question
uh
chair
wave off yes okay call the question
before us is senate bill 290 fn and act
relative to the practice of a recullo
therapy
and the motion is made by the chair to
interim study and seconded by
representative merchant
uh please call the roll
representative land yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay
representative dolan representative
folsom yes representative kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
kobalt yes representative delemus
representative mckay representative
knurk
yes representative soloway
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative query yes
representative pearson yes
okay
can we put this on consent
and committee blur
[Music]
okay so
close the uh exec session on 290. we
still have 15 minutes gosh for once in
my career i'm giving us enough time and
we're not running behind
uh senate bill 281 i'd like to open the
exact session on 281 we've already had
the hearing
and an act relative to nursing home
we have an amendment from weber
um
okay let's take a look and read
amendment 1335 as it's been passed
around
yeah they got to read it
we're not going to pass it so we'll find
out what's in it
i will clarify for them what's in it so
they know what they're doing what
let's try that yeah okay yeah all this
does um if you recall on the bill
lines five and six there was a sentence
the month in which the resident dies
shall be considered for the purpose of
rent and fees the last month of
residency it was pointed out at the
hearing that this was confusing because
this all has to do with making it 10
days for the rent and fees so what the
heck did this have to do with anything
and we all agreed it should be removed
so that's all this does if you do the
side by side of this you will find that
that sentence is deleted that's all that
happens because it only replaces
fully section one section two is the
effective date that stays there so
that's the only change in this bill
we know that the other
nursing homes lobbied for 15 days um
lucy decided not to change that to keep
it at the 10 because that seemed
reasonable and i think that's what we
all sort of felt at the hearing
the prime sponsor senator gannon wanted
it kept as is in the bill
really that's what he said why
no kept
attend
no yes i'm sorry i thought you meant the
30 days
we got rid of no no no yeah the 10. yes
yes he testified that he was he thought
10 was reasonable and so did we be all
representative canark would you like to
move the amendment yes i'd like to move
bill sb 281
any second from over here representative
acton
any further discussion
takes out that one sentence
the motion before us is ought to pass on
uh moved by representative kenner
seconded by representative acton um
please call the roll
representative lyon
representative mcmahon
representative acton representative gay
representative dolan
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
representative king
representative cofoult
representative delemus representative
mckay
representative knurk yes representative
soloway representative cannon
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative query yes
representative pearson yes
so now before us is senate bill 281 as
amended and the chair recognizes
representative cofould for a motion
i move ought to pass with amendment on
senate bill 281
and the second from over here
representative soloway
his hand beat it beat representative
seeing none
the motion before us
is senate bill 281
as amended by amendment 2022-1335
moved by representative kofol seconded
by representative soloway
please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative dolan representative
folsom yes representative kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
kofalt yes representative delemus
representative mckay
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes representative querrey yes
representative pearson yes and it passes
20 to 1.
20 to what
zero sorry
yes representative cofouls can say we
have to do it at least once he says
consent
saying no objections
concludes
exact session on 2 8
1.
we have 15 minutes almost
still so we can start the
exec session
on senate bill 4
establishing a supplemental nutrition
assistance program
and representative canark has an
amendment
um
yes
would you like me to walk people through
it
representative canark would you walk
people through it please the thing so um
just to remember what this bill is
this was the one that developed
actually directed dhhs to proceed with a
snap outreach program
they'd had one before uh they haven't
done one for a while
and we heard from the people
representing the new hampshire food bank
that it does a great deal of help to
let people be aware of what is available
in terms of snap benefits
so that they can sign up and get it so
this directed them to do it there were
two concerns that were brought up by
karen hebert who was uh from the bureau
one was on line 13 of the bill
so again the bill line 13
when it said the outreach plan should be
implemented within three months that is
after approval by the usda
the concern was that after it's approved
by the usda then it has to go out to bid
with the procurement process has to go
through the governor through the
executive council
and all that is likely to take a little
bit longer than just three months
so if you look at the amendment
on line five
and by the way what this amendment does
replaces
section
the first the first half of the
amendment replaces section one just
section a
so what it does is it changes it on line
five to six months
but we did add a phrase following the
state's current procurement process set
by the department of administrative
services
and that was just to make it clear
that
it was a six-month period and it was
because of the procurement process that
needs to be followed
so that is one half
the other portion that they had that the
department had some concerns about is in
the bill on line 24
it said the usda deadline for fiscal
year 2023
they wanted us to change that to the
state fiscal year so on line 11 of the
amendment it changes it to the usda
deadline for state fiscal year 20223 so
all that does is identify
whose fiscal year the federal government
versus the state keep it together with
the state
so that's all the amendment does it just
simply increases it for three months to
six months and it reinforces that they
have to go through the procurement
process and then it makes it the state
representative leon
um thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative kanark for bringing this
amendment those were definitely
important issues that were brought up by
karen hebert
i want to make sure everybody received
the email from karen hubert as well um
just to let everybody know she was asked
why the department discontinued the
program after 2017
and the data that she was able to report
from they had received 299 applications
per snap as a result of the outreach
of those applications 107 were opened
and the remaining 192 were denied mostly
for being over income or failure to
provide information and others withdrew
or didn't show up for the appointments
and for comparison purposes she stated
that without an outreach program in
place during the weeks ended march 4th
and march 25th of 2022 alone which was
for that time period the department
opened 4 415 snap cases and denied
another 2 244 for similar reasons to
above
um and she further said it may be
reasonable to say that 107 cases open as
a result of outreach was not an
effective outcome and it may have
subjected the program to further
evaluation so it seems that that that
representative
yes i did read that i think there's one
important thing to look at though and
that's the time frame
the data when they were doing the
outreach was 2015 to 2017.
the data
without that
outreach was march of 2022
in case somebody's been in a cave the
last few years there's been a little bit
of a problem that's gone on over the
last two years with the pandemic
with the economy not doing particularly
well
for the last
couple of years and it was booming
rather well back in 2015-17
people
need snap
when they're having trouble financially
they generally don't need not as many
people need snap when they're doing well
so the problem with this as with any
kind of
study that one does with an historical
control because that's what this is in
terms of a study design it's a
historical control
it is an entirely different period of
history and that's always the fallacy in
using historical controls unless you
know that the factors that would the
confounding factors that would influence
were the same the compounding factors
that influenced so the economy it was
vastly different in the early part of
2022 than it was in 2015-17
so it was nice she provided this but
it's totally useless data
from their data standpoint
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman while they do represent
different time periods i think my
biggest takeaway especially as an
economist
recognizes that people see that there
are these opportunities people know that
there's need and people most importantly
know this program exists
that's the whole point of snap outreach
is to let people know about it
and i think that i think that that
information is out there and i think the
department's efforts and resources are
representative folsom
um yes i looked at those numbers as well
and
what i really took from it was when
people are in need they go looking
and
they were able to find it obviously
pretty well
even during a pandemic
if nothing else they went online but um
so i'm not so sure that we necessarily
need an outreach program and
just the whole fact that you would have
to send it through the whole
bidding process and all of that
it's going to take up a lot of time
through the governor's office the
executive council everybody's going to
have to spend a lot of time on this
and i think there's time could be spent
better when people nowadays are
are getting more and more resourceful
about finding help on their own
sometimes we seem to go on the
assumption that everyone has internet
access or computer or phone that can
search these things out
and i know that to not be the case for
some of my neighbors
if if
passing this snap
outreach program
feeds
20 more families it's worth it so i'm
representative query
i knew this i actually never have heard
it before and he said it to me earlier
and i was like you gotta say that um i'm
surprised anyways
oh and it gets better because your first
name is joshua right yeah in hebrew it's
yeshua so i'm going to ask you are you
i'm out of material you may continue
all right um
i just want to build off of a
representative uh nutter upham's point
um
in early 2020 i
like many other people found themselves
unemployed
but however i was in the financial
situation where that wasn't as big of a
thing for many others so what i found
myself doing was volunteering at the
manchester welfare department
my job entirely for the four months that
i was there
was signing up people who were coming in
for other reasons for snap benefits they
did not know that that was a thing
even though they knew to come to the
welfare department so i really do think
an outreach program even if it is just
to point them in the direction of their
welfare departments
would be a very useful uh
you know useful for their time
representative gay
to follow up on what you're saying about
people coming for help
at least those people do get notified
about snap and for the people who don't
go to welfare
i'm thinking
it wouldn't hurt to post
but ask for a poster to be put in all
representative merchant
thank you mr chair
in regards to this
issue i look at it slightly differently
when we look at the numbers
back for two years we were in a
relatively strong economic position a
lot of people didn't need to have snap
when you look at the four weeks in march
there was 2171
qualified for snap
which is a large number
in many of those people probably for the
first time in their lives needed to have
public assistance
not because they chose it but because
the economy went against them
and i think at this point in time we're
still in a pandemic we have not got out
of it
i believe at this point in time building
awareness for people to at least have
access to the program
is not only helpful to them but to us as
a country because when they're not
getting the supplements that they need
particularly children folks
they go to the schools hungry and if you
ever been inside of a school and
dealt with children with an empty
stomach
it's hard they don't learn the
consequences to us as a society is huge
because when they don't have a good
education to begin with
long term we're paying more than what
the staff would cost us so from an
economic point of view this is in my
opinion very cost effective
because if you're helping the children
when they're young go to school
with a full belly full belly and have
the ability to learn the way they should
learn
for us as a society cost us far less
than the money this is going to cost us
thank you
representative kanark
thanks i wanted to respond to
representative gay's comment about
posters that could for example be
part of the outreach program or could be
the entire outreach program that's the
whole point this just asks them to
develop an outreach program
and then they would look at what are the
most effective ways to get that
information out it may be posters in
grocery stores it may also be posters in
a post office and other things like that
so that's the point is this does not
identify how they do it it just directs
them to do it and that might be one of
the things the other thing i point out
there just as a continuation we might
want to recess this because senator
apprentice is carefully uh patiently
waiting for her bill which is now three
minutes overdue
so we we might want to come back i'd
like to continue up until the amendment
process
anything further representative soloway
uh thank you mr chairman just quickly um
this is a cheap program the feds pay the
bulk of it or a major portion of it
the target population is the least
capable population in the state
if we manage to feed
a dozen more families that we wouldn't
have fed otherwise it will all have been
seeing no further
representative merchant just the
follow-up and representatives always
comment but i look at the fiscal note
there's no cost to state with this
so there's no downside as far as an
expense this is not going to hit a
general treasury at all
but the upside for a lot of those who
need the assistance is huge
so
from an economic point of view this is
not going to come to the state treasury
for us to bail it out this is a program
coming from uncle sam if you will which
ultimate comes from us but still
it doesn't cost us here and the
taxpayers in new hampshire any dollars
i'm looking at an unnumbered the lines
aren't numbered in what i printed out
but if i go down under 13 b about six or
seven lines
nothing in this paragraph shall be
construed to prevent the department's
use of available general fund
appropriations for the purpose of this
paragraph if there are insufficient
federal or private funds available
how does that speak representative
kanark
sorry in the fiscal note the comment is
that um
it is expected to that this can be
accomplished within the department's
existing budget the point is they expect
they will have the appropriate gifts um
that's apparently already lined up but
the issue is they didn't want to have to
come back if that one of those fell
through and they needed an extra twenty
dollars
so they don't have to even ask for an
appropriation it's already can be
covered in the existing budget
representative folsom
um in the methodology portion of the
fiscal note it says the department is
unable to estimate the amount of funds
that that may be received or any
resulting impact on the unit utilization
of snap benefits
so
i don't know how they can say they can
cover it in their program when they are
unable to estimate the difference it
costs well that's received
as revenue
that's not cost
in other words these this is this is
money that would be coming into the
state because of snap benefits that's
why they can't estimate how much would
be received
it's the money coming in from the united
states department of agriculture i still
look at this phrase that says
if insufficient federal or private funds
i mean i'm not speaking here to the
merits of the program itself i'm
speaking to assertions about uh who
funds it in case
well let's
i think there's two separate things here
one is there's the issue of what it
costs to run a program is also the issue
about building awareness of the program
this is talking about building the
awareness of the program when the
program may grow because the needs there
the cost to run the program as far as
the food and so forth is coming the
united states department of agriculture
not from a state so therefore when you
start looking at the cost to run the
program that's borne by the federal
government the cost to build the
awareness of the program is borne by our
state which is incorporating the
department's budget representative leon
thank you mr chairman when we look at
the fiscal note it says the department
notes that in its normal course of
business it already plans to apply for
snap outreach plan as part of its august
submission so they're already planning
to do this
um it doesn't it says that it limits it
to only if it's fully funded by private
or federal sources but it's allowed to
go through the general fund if they're
already planning to do this
we can let them continue to do that
without having to pass this law
because the point was to put this into
the stat they said that they wanted this
again i go back to when i look at what's
going on here representative leon
to your point
the cost to run the program is coming
from the federal government that money
goes away for the most part life is
going to wait the program today exists
does it not yes the programming so
therefore all we're trying to do is
build awareness of the program
so if the program already exists all the
financial things we're talking about are
going to occur regardless
all we're doing at this point in time is
trying to build more awareness of the
program so people can benefit from it
but the cost to run the program because
it already exists
is going to be incurred whether we pass
thank you um we're going to move the
question on amendment
not the bill amendment
1386 to senate bill 404 fn establishing
a supplemental nutrition assistance
program
it uh was it is to be moved actually we
have not the question on the floor so it
has to be put but i mean it has to be
moved before we put representative
connect i move amendment 1386
to senate bill 404. a second
representative nada upham
okay now
the question would the clerk please call
representative leon
uh yes representative mcmahon
representative acton no
representative gay
representative cushman i'm sorry
representative dole dolan
sorry i forgot to write that in ahead of
time i got caught up in the discussion
uh representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
no
representative cofoult
yes
representative delemus
representative
mckay yeah
representative snow
is still absent representative knurk yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative query
yes
the amendment passes 17 1723
we will recess the exec session on
senate bill 404
and we now open the hearing on senate
bill
408.
[Music]
an act directing the department of
health and human services to make
adjustments to the facility fee
reimbursement schedule for freestanding
birthing centers this has become an
early bill
because um
[Music]
representative omburger waved off
hearing it so
we can look at the fiscal note like
with the finance committee
all right the chair recognizes senate
apprentice
good morning and uh thank you
uh chair pearson and members of
house health and human services and
elderly affairs again for the record my
name is suprentist i'm the state senator
from district five
beautiful connecticut river valley nine
communities
and i'm here today to introduce senate
bill 408 which directs the department of
health and human services to adjust the
facility reimbursement schedule for
freestanding birthing centers under
medicaid specifically to make the rate
comparable to the hospital rates the
facility fee under medicaid for these
centers
and from what i can tell
there this has not been changed
maybe ever or in a number of years
we're seeking to raise that rate um
which is included in the fiscal note to
921 dollars again this is under medicaid
making a comparable
rising this to taking this and raising
it up to comp to be comparable with a
hospital rate but not parity
today there are five freestanding
birthing centers in new hampshire
concord lebanon milford
salem and swansea
family choices for obstetric care
for their childbirth experience it
matters licensed freestanding birthing
centers offer this choice
over the past 20 years we've seen 10
hospital-based delivery units close here
in new hampshire
the most recent is parkland medical
center in derry and that was in 2020. we
can't lose sight of the overall struggle
that our obstetric obstetrical care
services face in our state
raising this medicaid facility
reimbursement rate is one step an
important step in the right direction in
support of our state's families who
choose freestanding birthing centers for
how they will welcome their newest and
our newest
granite staters the smallest members of
their families as well as ours
i'd like to thank the committee for its
time and consideration of senate bill
408 i look forward to answering the
questions that i can answer um
and
i will end my my introduction my
testimony there
you're a breath of fresh air we get
people answer questions they shouldn't
so thank you for saying that
representative connerk
thank you very much is it true that even
at the medicaid rate that it doesn't
even begin to cover their costs
thank you mr
yes
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question just
for
sort of running on the same uh avenue
that we just started with the last
question what is comparable in terms of
for the same i'm not sure what this
dollar amount covers
because there's a lot more
ivs and medications everything else what
does this cover
and what is what would be a similar
charge
if it were private insurance
um
so we have something to compare it to
absolutely thank you for the question so
i do have director lipman with me here
from
the department of health and human
services who would be able to drill down
further into this uh but and again this
is we're talking about comparable we're
not talking about parity we know that
the cost to run these freestanding birth
descent centers is different than it
would be for a hospital and that's why
we're not seeking parity here but i can
we defer that question to um director
littman
the remainder of it
representative merchant
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
taking my question
we had a very long
discussion on house bill 1044
dealing with market competition
and people in this committee voted to
increase market competition
in essence by having freestanding
birthing centers is that not in fact
increasing or allowing us to have
greater access for patients but also
bring market competition to the
forefront
representative merchant that's a great
question um i think that it it does in a
sense bring market competition it offers
more choices but i do want to point out
that i believe that this
complements the health care system
nicely i think we're all aware that
there are ambulatory care centers
that are doing you know their
freestanding that are doing surgical
procedures some of them affiliated with
hospitals some of them
not
that have been existing in new hampshire
for a number of years so this is very
similar along those lines the way that i
see it
thank you thank you senator
representative gay
thank you
thank you very much for
bringing such a good sensible bill would
you believe
thank you senator you're welcome the
chair recognizes henry lippman and
i don't think trisha is here but i think
i can hopefully cover the questions
i have faith in you thank you she's down
in center hhs you're still looking well
tanned mr luke
i guess i can start by answering a
couple of questions that were out there
um the question in terms of when we did
comparable typical average length of
stay for birth is like 2.2 days so what
we did is we calculated the per diem of
the current drg rate
the per diem being a day
and since most of the birthing centers
are
a
day
service that's how we came up with with
that
in terms of um
competition and access i think that
particularly the facility in swansea
you know we have heard concerns about
other hospitals
um being able to maintain obstetric
services one of the areas we're worried
about is in that region
and i think
the
lead constituent i think that approached
senator apprentice was from that area i
think it's a it's a sensible bill i'm
glad to hear that there's support on it
um i think we need to
you know the obstetric situation the
state is very fragile generally and i
think preserving this option
um you know this is a step i'm not sure
it's the final step that we need to take
in terms of all the birthing situations
in the state but at least it buys us
some time so that we're not dealing with
a crisis
merchant representative merchant thank
you mr chairman thank you miss lip for
taking my question
my understanding is that when you look
at the medicaid
payment system it's predicated upon an
icd-9 code and basically it doesn't
matter where that procedure is being
operated it's the same rate
whether it's done in a hospital than a
clinic and so forth based upon parity if
you will within the code structure would
this not bring greater parity in that
regard because we'd have standardization
of again the same thing where we have
parity between different providers the
same procedure
i think that um
the way i had to do some research on
this myself that the birthing centers
were set up uh a little bit differently
than hospitals in this instance um sort
of if you kind of think about it as uh
there's not necessarily a facility if he
it's a
and so
you know just in terms of trying to come
up with something that made
some logical sense in terms of
benchmarking and against what a hospital
incurs and understanding that it's only
going to be for a shorter time
i think that's that's how we approached
it
thank you
welcome
chair recognizes james monahan
we wrote up here today
didn't get much of a chance for a
conversation though because it was only
that's uh stalling for time he's got
handouts there was only one story i'm
sorry
what's that
oh
yes and somebody's trying to elevate
this to what over there
however we all know that what goes up
now you've been here for a few hearings
yeah
thank you mr
chairman um
so as you observe my name is uh jim
monahan i'm with the uh dupont group and
just one second we're we're don't all
have the kind of the 24 that it
passed out if they would make it right
okay somebody's got two
[Music]
you may proceed though great sir thank
you uh mr chairman my name is jim
monahan i'm with the dupont group and we
volunteer some of our time with the new
hampshire midwives association so i'm
happy to be working with the legislature
and the department on this bill this
year um mary lowey from the um
midwives association had hoped to be
here today but wasn't able to make it
and so the letter that i presented is
really from her um i don't have a lot to
add uh and when i heard representative
gay say you like it almost said maybe i
shouldn't testify
but um
um but just to add you know the the
letter from uh mary does offer some
observations about how the medicaid
reimbursement for the birthing sentence
is is remarkably low
um and so when we began working in this
issue with the department we very much
did not want to come in and say it has
to be exactly the same as hospitals and
that's why we came to the conclusion
that a comparable rate which would take
into account the differential facilities
costs as representative woods observed
would be the best way to do it
but the department felt that the
direction from the legislature undertake
the rulemaking was necessary and that's
what brings us here today
uh you will see that the uh and mary's
letter that they estimate the facilities
costs are really probably closer to
three thousand dollars
and what we're asking for is very modest
increase in the rate and a big part of
that is to try to ensure that the
birthing centers
can continue to care for
medicaid families at time of birth and
not have such a perverse negative
incentive
to do so i think ultimately what
we hope to see moving forward uh is in
those areas that are underserved that we
create the right market signals for
birthing centers to open in the north
country and more rural parts of the
state so i'll do my best to answer any
questions you might have if i'm unable
to i can communicate with mary lower and
if we have an extra copy of this i i
think representative cushman should
probably get it huh
i'll leave it
i'll leave it for her
she may need it
thank you mr chairman
i'm just curious to know do do you have
numbers of the
population who are taking advantage of
or or utilizing uh the medicaid programs
in these freestanding uh yeah it's not a
huge number um i think um
from the data we've seen i apologize not
having with me that i think there were
68 uh births at birthing centers from
medicaid families uh last year uh that
was slightly higher because of the
pandemic i think people were
more perhaps more reluctant to be in
hospitals um and so
um i think with the fiscal note is on
average we're probably looking for at
least with the five centers there now uh
50 medicaid births a year
thank you
and i think that compares to 3 500
um for hospital births
representative knurk uh yes and just in
terms of the responsibility of the
birthing centers
um they are required under 151 2f to
accept all payers
so indeed them doing this
it does have a negative impact if
they're not getting reimbursed a
reasonable amount correct yes is that
right would you believe or i should say
is that correct thank you
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question if you're not the right person
to ask you can let me know okay um i was
curious if you know how many births
happen in these freestanding birthing
centers um
in general not just the medicaid
reversed ones i'll get that answer to
you um so okay um
thank you i'm curious i don't want to
make this mistake of guessing but we can
did she just ask that it's like 3 500
hospital births in the year or were you
talking about 3 500 births at the
birthing centers
that was me my observation was i think
there's 3 500 medicaid births in
hospitals per year as opposed to only 50
at the birthing centers but
representative leon's question was
which i didn't have the answer to which
is what are the total number of births
that have taken place at the five
birthing centers on the annual basis and
thank you madam chair
and also thank you for taking my
question
in the letter
thank you for providing this to us from
mary waller
she made a comment it's
not just the economics here but if you
look in the third paragraph on her
letter
it talks about this strong starting
shift for mothers and newborns for the
centers of medicare and medicaid
reported that
women who received care participating
birthing centers had fewer preterm
births lower
low birth weight babies and caesarean
sections
so therefore economically speaking is
this not a positive thing because
in a lot of ways having
patients that receive that kind of care
are incurring less cost to the health
care system than if they would otherwise
so this is really kind of an economic
would you agree with the fact that it's
not just the question of
access and the ability to be taken care
of but from an economic point of view
overall care for the
mother who's having a child is less
costly
uh yes i'd agree with that and that's
why
you know as we elevated this history we
certainly heard from the payer community
that they wanted to be supportive as
well because they they want to have that
less costly option
i suspect that
well
not to error literalize too much i'm
when a family chooses a birthing center
i don't think it's necessarily an
economic decision
maybe in part but there are other
follow up
thank you
i totally agree i don't think it's
economics what drives the decision but i
think from us evaluating this bill and
the merits to it there's not just the
access question but also the economic
side of the equation so economically
supporting this bill helps us
financially at the same time helping if
you will those making the wise choice i
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thanks for
taking my question uh so
this small increase would help with the
viability
um and if i understand it correctly
this would also help
them with the prenatal and postnatal
services that they provide at the center
is that correct
uh subject to director lippmann nodding
one way or the other i think mostly what
focused on here is the facility charge
uh and not the other associated charges
with uh with the births i guess
i guess but
that's part of the picture for them to
be viable
yes and if they're not viable then they
would
then subsequently not be able to offer
the other services as well that is
correct
seeing no further questions uh thank you
okay i'll just i'll get it
so i'm sorry
senator princess is
right on top of things and getting an
answer to her i think representing this
question but i i didn't want to
read it but anyway please before the day
is over perhaps we'll get you an answer
okay
having no
having no further pink cards
the chair assigns uh the duties of
kelsey
thank you and you have joint custody of
close the hearing on
the hearing we just had
senate bill
408. and open the exact session on the
same
and the chair recognizes representative
folsom for
a motion
i move ought to pass on senate bill
and do we have a second second
discussion
representative leon uh thank you mr
chairman i think that this is a
fantastic bill i think that we need to
support a whole spectrum of birthing
options to support different families
different choices and especially allow
some of these lower risk births to
happen
in a different place so that those who
need the more intensive management and
care in a hospital setting are able to
get in there and able to spend that time
with those specialists and i like that
we're embracing the midwifery standard
of care and i'm very happy to vote for
this bill representative
folsom
i love birthing centers
representative woods
uh yes um i i'm very much in favor of
this uh just from my own practice it's
experience
in our office uh we looked at the
numbers and on across the board for our
orthopedic services we got 25 cents on
the dollar
on average compared on the average
that's not considering high or low but
on average you've got 25 cents on a
dollar
for any service compared to what we
would get with uh standard insurance
representative kanark
thank you very much i fully support this
but i did want to point out because i
think you all know i'm a bit of a
stickler for science
in the third option sorry the third
paragraph of the letter when it talks
about the decreased cost for birthing
centers which makes it sound like it's
really much much more efficient do
remember that this is not
equal or they're not equivalent uh
study populations because there's a
pre-selection people with
known complicated births uh who are
expecting difficult births older any
kind of things they're not going to be
going to a birthing center they'll be
directed to a hospital so
though this sounds like it's incredibly
more efficient it's not as efficient but
i still think this is the right thing
and it will probably
it is i think
representative leon said unload the
hospitals of the more routine cases and
provide people options so it's a good
bill
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman um
i
do support this bill and i will vote for
it but my initial reaction was that
medicaid rates are
really
low for many many things and um as a
board member of a local community mental
medicaid rates are um
to a great extent responsible for the
fact that we can't find uh staff at our
mental health center um and mental
health centers all over the state so um
i do support this i think the um
availability of
places to give birth around the state is
a particularly vulnerable service but i
hope that we will come back here next
year and be
generous also with the
need to rate med to raise medicaid rates
for um
either across the board or for other
um
services that are
underfunded
hearing the music
that means
no one else
i see no one else
so the motion before us
is ought to pass on senate bill 408
move by representative folsom seconded
by representative woods
i would love to
representative leon
yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative dolan yes
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes
representative cofold yes
representative mckay
representative
snow's not here no he is yes
oh representative snow and his mic son
too
representative snow
he only gets to vote once oh did he vote
okay yeah
we were all laughing sorry you couldn't
hear
representative kenner yes representative
soloway
shapiro
yes
representative woods yes
and representative merchant
yes
and representative query
yes and representative pearson yes
21-0
consent
i wasn't going that far
and the next one's not up till 11
o'clock we are making we'll be out of
yeah when they were talking to me about
who what wants to come to be subs here i
well we've got 10 minutes um do we want
why not okay reopening
the executive session
when you last tuned in the amendment was
approved 17 to 3.
now we are um on the bill and the chair
recognizes representative leon for a
motion
um thank you mr chairman i move interim
study because the department's already
doing this
do we have a second representative
cofault seconds it now discussion
thank you mr chairman in the fiscal note
it states that the department is already
planning to do that for that reason i
think that
keeping our laws short and sweet we
allow them to continue to do what
they're planning to do put in an interim
study so that they know that
just put in an interim study and move
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman it's cheap
it sends a message it's compassionate
it's easy to do costs us nothing i think
representative canark
yes i think one of the other things that
came up during the hearing was that this
um although they
are sort of probably going to be working
on it that's a sort of problem maybe and
this puts a prod to say we want you to
uh which i think tells us
sends a message that we'd like them to
actually do this and not just maybe do
it but maybe sweep it under the rug if
they don't get around to it
representative leon
thank you mr chairman that's
that same point is why i moved to
interim study because they said that
they're already going to do it this is
encouragement for them to go ahead and
continue on that path without having to
put it into law we could start a group
anyone else representative merchant
thank you mr chair
uh
document that just handed to us which is
the new hampshire physical policy
institute which i have a lot of respect
for
and being truly a
bipartisan group
when you look at page seven
this is kind of what i'm trying to get
to i think with of us as well
on page seven if you look at the snap
program enrollment as percent of the
population below the 200 percent poverty
level
we're coming at a dismal folks a dismal
30 percent
people to our
east main is 40 vermont to our west is
45 to our south massachusetts 54.
we have a long ways to go
in trying to close that gap
oh
i thought you all
in that case mr chairman let's wait for
the
okay we'll wait until we have the
document before we discuss the document
any other
comments we are an exact session we
don't even have to keep up the pretense
yes representative mcmahon thank you mr
chairman
i come to the table on on this issue as
one who um from this committee we did a
tremendous amount of work
years ago regarding the
program it's the snap program itself
and the
on the ground use of the program that
was being at the time
uh
disparaged that it was being abused
ripped off at stores etc etc and uh that
the folks and families
utilizing it
were not qualified to use it
i happen to be the chair of the
committee that did the oversight on this
and what we found that the facts put by
those
who brought the bill to the table to
frankly take snap off the table
were incorrect and not only incorrect it
was fake
what was fake was when in doubt people
made things up
and when the data was reviewed
it was found that less than one tenth of
one percent had issues and that was
dealing with when you're in a store
could you purchase
pre-made
food think of a chicken the answer was
no
you're supposed to have the
and still the case today
you're supposed to have it for your home
to take care of your family and your
children and not using it
uh for trade just outside
the door and that's when those drug use
issues played a role in that discussion
etc
what we just supported here
was in 408
was the genesis of families human beings
and stating that we want to make it cost
effective that the best health care will
provide the best result during birth
well now that we have that sustainable
support
we now need to sustain the result of
that effort in my view and based on the
years on this committee
is holding people responsible for taking
care
of what they brought into this world and
that's
young children
and also by the way our aggressively
mature population otherwise known as
elderly
just for the record
uh
and if one i uh walks the talk of of
being responsible self-respect
self-reliance or self-determination
this issue
here is to let
individuals know
and many are individuals but it's
many single parents
who are left to take care of their
children
on their own and themselves
that this program be facilitated in
terms of notice
and that an impetus to our
infrastructure
at health and human services
know that there is a commitment from
us together
that this be done while we're young
the sustainability of this program is
not to add the cost it's to reduce the
investment in the result
of not doing something
and the something here is notification
knowledge
and and holding folks accountable to
follow the rules and like uh in closing
i can tell you
that this committee
this entity where it happened right here
we found that
new hampshire people
the vast majority
do follow the rules
they also have pride and self-respect
and it's
many times a difficult
challenge for them to
say i need help
they need to know that help is here
that it'll allow them to build from
there to not have help in perpetuity
and that's why i'm one that does support
this effort here
and also being cost effective as well
because i do believe in that we need to
hold people accountable
but that it's not a
program that will always be there
for the individual is to get them
transitioning off
from when they need assistance and that
we all discuss many variations on that
but
basic food right from birth on
so that you can build from
that area
so i'm what i'm asking everyone here is
um i do
bring
some
personal experience i've learned right
here on this committee
it's it's not to give something away for
nothing
but uh it's to take care of our citizens
here those who need it and this is uh
knowledge that they need to know
to make the right decisions and i'm
hoping that you'll support
the intent
of the
404 bill
thank you madam chairman
um thank you uh representative kanark
i just want to clarify representative
mcmahon i agree with everything you said
so does that mean you're planning to
vote against the interim study to vote
for otp if that comes forth and it's
amazing how you have a continuity of
intelligence to understand that
well i was i was pretty sure but i
wanted to make sure that that was
abundantly clear to everyone thank you
that yes sir
my attempted humorous side yes that is
correct
representative gay
thank you
um i noticed on page seven a confusing
upsetting line
uh
pardon
on oh that's right y'all don't have this
oh there we go um thank you if you could
actually suspend on that representative
gate it will if can we have um i don't
know if you want to get into this
representative merchant or if we want to
move into the 11 o'clock hearing and
then we'll resume this
let's
recess and yes okay yeah thank you then
this recess is the executive the
executive session on
house bill 404.
and now actually i still need to get
that card i appreciate you doing that
this is a great discussion to be able to
have do you have the cards for 419 uh
only have one thank you
and um this opens the hearing on senate
bill 419
and we call senator apprentice back to
good morning and
thank thank you uh
so representative leon you'll be
cheering
okay so i'll be directing through you
good morning again for the record state
senator sue prentice
wonderful upper connect well connecticut
river valley nine communities happy to
be here before you today
i am introducing
senate bill 419 which establishes a
commission to study the delivery of
public health services in new hampshire
through the 13 regional public health
networks so i just want to i'm going to
share a little history i won't take up
too much time but i want to put this in
context that public health is
you know is in a is a community-based
approach to the health and well-being of
of everyone and our families and it
ranges from i know we've heard a lot
about it during covet 19 but i'd ask you
to broaden your thinking on this uh to
h1n1 to childhood obesity to child
passenger safety to mental health to
drug addiction whatever particular issue
or issues are facing a community that's
where a public health team
comes in
i have some experience in this area
working
when i worked as the chief of emergency
medical services for the department of
safety
was during the days when we were
actually taking working with these
public health networks and
really
taking some of the first steps to
further institutionalize and memorialize
their regional approach in new hampshire
so with that in mind
i want to just you know share a little
history so in the late 1990s turning
point grants helped establish these
networks
that approach the delivery of public
health services throughout the country
but here in new hampshire bringing
together communities that traditionally
share services including fire mutual aid
emergency medical services mutual aid
health care
hospital health care type of systems
and that are geographically aligned as
well as again work with the same
hospital and health care communities
as you already know
their not every community has a public
health department a full-time public
health department exists in manchester
it exists in in nashua and then i
understand we now have a part-time
public health department in portsmouth
so the rest of the state relies on these
regional networks to you know be the
kind of the watchers and the helpers
when there are
public health issues that arise so i
think that that is important to
understand
in the mid 2000s federal dollars came to
new hampshire
to build out the public health emergency
preparedness capacity and again that is
actually the part that i was most
intimately involved in in new hampshire
and most notably place the
responsibility for this type of response
with our public health networks
many of you have come to know the work
of our public health networks through
coven 19 setting up
sites for testing
setting up sites for vaccination but
setting up like well
testing vaccination but i'd also
like you to think back if you can
remember
some of these issues there was a
hepatitis outbreak at a fast food
restaurant in the central part of new
hampshire years ago when i worked at the
department of safety and the way that
they were actually able to help many
people get the necessary medication out
to folks was actually through
a public health network
and again consider that these networks
work together
they have common they overlap in many
ways and that's how they become i want
to say good friends in partners and
taking care of the public but they are
dealing with other
issues again child passenger safety
would be an issue childhood obesity
managing
drug you know drug addiction in their
community as well as mental health
responses
each area of the state may have a
different focus for public health but
somebody has to be watching this in
order to be able to address this
the state's health improvement plan
cites regional approaches and
infrastructure for public health as
priorities independent c specifically
what forces of change are impacting new
hampshire includes a focus on addressing
the limited public health capacity and
ability to respond to emerging issues
this included language or includes the
regional public health networks
now more than ever we understand the
importance of a coordinated delivery
system and the work that public health
networks can and have performed
but we don't i'm coming forward with
this
this bill to form a study commission
because we have answers we don't have
answers to questions and we don't have
an infrastructure that is built out in
the state that's consistent we have
again regional approaches that are doing
the best they can
with limited funding sources we have
some full-time departments but it leaves
us with questions about how this should
best be done and that's what i'm asking
you to consider today
so
this commission would review the
operations of the 13 public health
networks i want to be clear that even if
you're in manchester or nashua or
portsmouth and you may have you know
funded public health capacity you're
still part of these networks so it's a
very inclusive way of doing their work
review the regional public health
priorities across the state
propose a plan for the provision and
implementation of sustainable programs
practices governance and policies that
are evidence-based to improve health
outcomes across new hampshire
review the management of public health
emergencies at the state and local level
review the coordination of services
among partners to include local public
health officers and propose a plan for
how to optimize these services
so again this is a commission to study
which i think is a question a series of
questions that need to be answered and
that commission
would then report out before any actions
were taken so i've been studying this
you know kind of you know from my uh you
know my home in lebanon and my prior
work in the state for years and thinking
about what's the best approach and so
i'm asking you to join me in broadening
your thinking about public health
investing in and this is not a financial
investment investment this is a policy
investment well a strategic policy
investment and setting up a commission
to answer questions that i have but i
bet that you have as well
so i will conclude my testimony i'll do
my best to answer any questions that you
have and i see hands going up i'm ready
okay representative leon
uh representative folsom
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um reading through the bill i just want
to confirm this looks like a a one and
done kind of commission
get together review this
provide a report the commission ends
correct is that okay thank you you're
welcome thank you for the question
representative representative kanark
thank you very much uh yes i had a
question i serving as the chair of the
state health assessment state health
improvement plan advisory council
currently in our march meeting we did
have a report
from the
new hampshire health officer association
and we are that's part of our charge as
well so i was glad to hear you reference
the previous ship and the question is is
there any redundancy or do you see that
these are complementary where ship
guides the ship shall we say is where
we're going to go and this is the idea
of how to actually then implement it
with the boots on the ground is that are
they complementary to one another and
not redundant i i think they're
complementary i don't think that they're
redundant um and i also think that this
if i may quickly that
it will answer questions whether there's
implementation or not is to be decided
but these questions i believe need to be
answered first thank you very much thank
you
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question uh certainly
public health uh is
of paramount importance and its
coordination is eve even uh to make it
useful has to be coordinated to say the
least i do have concerns however
this is to me as i read this and maybe
it's my ignorance showing is a huge
ask
when i say review the court uh a purpose
or provision implementation of
sustainable programs practices
governance policies that are evidenced i
mean that is i mean that is really very
broad
and
to put that together i mean that's still
certainly doable and certainly if you
look at but
i'm concerned uh that
that it would terminate in six months
so here we have a commission
to do this huge
job which is certainly needed but isn't
the the november 20 of of this year a
little
soon
um i'm very concerned about that
yes
yes so
representative am i hearing you saying
that you think
that
the period of time for the work of the
commission is not long enough correct i
just for the magnitude of the ask
the time frame especially
with the difficulty getting commissions
together we're told
um remember and also uh it's summer uh
it's gonna be hard to get people from
around and also it's election year
uh
people are going to be you know so all
factors together from a functional
perspective
i
i would just hate to see it
okay would the senator be interested in
an amendment
simply stretching it out further
committee amendment to stretch it out
further we could do a committee
amendment here um
would you like that i would
representative woods how long do you
think it would be
feasible my perspective i again i'm not
in the public health here and i'm not
familiar with these areas so i don't
know how complex it is but i would think
so i would
may i
thank you um i'm amenable to additional
time and up to a year and if we can
complete our work uh before that then
then we'll will be done i understand
it's a big job i mean there are 13
regional public health networks and i
want to make sure that
they all you know they all are at the
table so thank you let me interrupt here
at this point because i'm about to ask
the committee um researcher if she would
continue
to write out that amendment just
changing it one year further
amendment woods pearson can can work on
that and just want us before she hit
send make sure that that sounds pretty
good to us just nod
you're nodding all in the same direction
okay hit send thank you
uh where were we representative merchant
if that amendment the other option could
be from this work of this group is one
of the outcomes could be the fact that
we want to extend it so the amendment
takes care of that but if it hadn't been
for the amendment i was going to make a
comment that
the outcome of this commission even
though it's short-lived could be the
fact that we need to continue it
it just was an option itself okay
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
since
since you're bringing this forward and
since there already are regional public
health
groups
i assume that there's a problem that
we're trying to fix so i wonder if you
could
give
some examples of
deficiencies in the system we have now
that have maybe been uncovered with
recent crises i mean covet is the
obvious example but it could be other
things
what are the shortcomings in our system
as
as it exists currently
thank you for the question
representative shapiro so the
shortcoming or shortcomings that that i
see that i want to address is the fact
that we don't
have
really a permanent type of system like a
backbone that's built out in new
hampshire we know we have these networks
we know that they do a good job they
work under contract with health and
human services they have mixed sources
of funding and i don't see that ending
but what it does is it it leaves this
big hole well the funding ending but
what if the funding did end um and
where are we without a you know like a
permanent backbone do we need a
permanent structure for this and that's
that's the question like
they are working hard and doing a good
job not all of them are equal as well
and that's not saying that one
public health network isn't doing
you know as good a job as another but
their their size and some of them depend
on volunteers to do some of their work
you know there's
there's so many layers to this that i
find it find it complicated and i what i
want to do is help these organizations
and help the state look at what their
future is for a public health
infrastructure
it might be more consistency across the
board more uniformity between their
practices
but it it might not depending on what
gets said what gets said and worked on
within this group
so that is the best that is really where
my focus is what's the what's the
backbone what are we going to do thank
you you're welcome thank you
representative snow
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my
question i noticed at the end there is
currently apparently under rsa 127
colon 12
a
commission to study
public health systems throughout new
hampshire which is going to be repealed
now i don't know what you mean by study
did they establish a plan
like you're proposing to do always this
to study
kind of a
a committee to encourage collaboration
among the regional networks and to work
together
or is the assumption if this is now
repealed
the only thing holding all those
networks together is the department of
human health and human services that's
correct so that and that's and
you think that's enough to really
because i think one of the things i
worked a good deal i spent a good deal
of time working with the manchester
regional public which i'm very impressed
with by the way and the people who work
down there are really top top of the
line
and they do encourage getting involved
with other communities and i think
collaborating with smaller communities
that come along and
both in terms of coaching and making
suggestions is a good idea and i would
not want to see anything happen with
thank you representatives there's your
question if this
if if this delivery you know the study
on public health services were to be
pulled back that it might have a
negative impact
yes well if that seems to be the only
committee that connects them
other than that all have contracts with
the department of health and human
services
but
sometimes a committee like this
in a more informal way encourage more
this would be yeah so this would be this
would be all-encompassing and
all-inclusive so it would be in its
place
but the commission ends
when you're proposing ends the
commission would end but this also here
um is john williams in the room john
do you want to come up here can i
represent you absolutely he lives here
you know that yes i know and i work
certainly with my um my friends at dhhs
on this so there's a commission to study
the delivery of public health services
isn't this the repeal of this commission
this this rep this is the repeal date
for this commission that's exactly what
this does it's a very nice cleanup so
when it sunsets it's actually provides
provision for the repeal and the sunset
yes and again the inclusiveness so that
everything would move forward that that
committee does not
i thought this was a separate committee
from the one that you're proposing and
this is going out of business and this
is replacing it and that's not the case
and and you don't really feel we need to
have a
oversight committee to look at that well
this commission could establish either
re-establish that or something similar
thank you those are those are like the
lingering questions okay thank you
you're welcome
thank you john williams representative
soloway
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
senator um and i
brief statement
leading up to the question and this is
in the context of the chairman's known
and it's my job it's not necessarily my
preference
speaking as someone who has some
expertise in the area of community
health i would like to say that our
public health system here in new
hampshire is right up there timely and
medieval
and our ability to handle
the public health threats
is right up there with our establishment
of arms houses indentured servitude the
burning of witches to stop outbreaks and
bloodletting
and what we're talking about doing is
creating a commission which will issue a
report which will gather substantial
amounts of dust probably with microbes
within it
that will sit on a shelf
would this not work better here's the
question would this not work better
as a standing committee of the oversight
committee on health and human services
because as representative woods points
out this is a huge task it's an ongoing
task and we need to put a structure in
place that's going to build and maintain
a public health system wouldn't that
would the representative add leeches to
that list
i think i heard leeches
honestly
no i'd like you to lie through your
teeth
i don't
i haven't thought about it that way i'm
just going to be completely frank so
maybe frank was better perfectly is
better so frank's in the other committee
but okay in the other committee not here
i had not thought about it that way i
mean i i am open
um i i'm open to changes i just want to
you know my ultimate goal here is i know
it's a big task but it is it is worth
doing and we have questions i mean i i
tried to do this a different way and
came down really on having us a
commission so that we could you know we
could
spend our time do the do the work that
we need answer these questions and then
be completely you know completely clear
because we're not right now
representative sullivan what's
interesting
you've got the chairman
of this committee and the chairman of
oversight talking to himself at the
moment
and
his conclusion is that let's run with
what's being established here and one of
the things they may conclude
is wouldn't they like to
okay representative gay
thank you
excuse me
i'm really impressed with the scope of
the people that you have put
suggested be on this commission i'm
really um
i would want to maintain whatever is
done includes this wide arena
like you said
it's open and inclusive because as you
said some some of the organizations are
much more
large and powerful and others are very
small and if they
in order to be effective
there has to be really good
communication avenues and sometimes if
you don't establish
you know everybody's okay to email each
other here's the list you can do free
exchange of ideas if it just turns into
uh we're gonna have a meeting
a meeting we'll point something we'll
make a report that's not ongoing so i
like
i i i
i don't know how to say would you
believe in this connection
would you believe it hilarity said
honestly but now now i'm going to use
frankly okay
well frankly frankly i i like really
like the idea and i'm trying to figure
out how
we make sure that it's ongoing
and that it's accessible
um
and
even though it seems like it would make
sense what do you think here that's a
good one what do you think
if we put it
i can't make this into a sentence i'm
asking her here's my idea how do you
feel about it and just to put it as a
subsidiary
subsidiary on your commission
that might change who's on it
so
i'm thinking let them figure out how to
how to keep on going because it's not
just oh we're going to check out all
this it's like how do we make a really
good response team for whatever's
happening
how do we build a real you know a
consistent reliable backbone i think
about it but you know backbone
infrastructure's a word we use a lot but
really four-part for public health in
this state for public health delivery
systems and that's you know that is
what's embedded in here and it's gonna
and there i mean i i will say that it
was hard
to prescribe the membership for this
because there were so many people
13 public health networks need to be
represented and they can bring about who
they want to put their um i
who they want to have represent them
it's important and i've i've talked with
other groups who've called me and said
you know gi how come my group isn't in
this and i said you these are public
meetings this is open you are welcome
and part of what i was on a commission
once when i worked in emergency medical
services i was appointed to a commission
to put automatic external defibrillators
in all public schools so we had a mix of
legislators and different folks from
health care and public safety and that's
part we were very deliberate about the
transparency in the meetings and making
sure not just who we had prescribed at
the table but
as questions developed and as we started
to go down certain to certain avenues
you know working through certain ideas
we would make sure to invite the right
you know people to be there
and so that could as this all takes
place
either make this
i don't want to say larger because that
that it is inclusive we can be inclusive
without all of the names but it could
you know broaden the group that's in
involved in this um rather than draw it
back that's yet to be seen so i hope
that that helps
um i think that i hope that that helps
with your question and any worry that
you might have
have you a senator in mind who might be
frankly no
keep lying
[Laughter]
yeah yes yes that's all i ask and do you
have a representative
not at this moment okay because is the
one that has to go scout all of these
things this has become a requirement now
would you like to
maybe
answer the question again do you have a
representative in mind i would
i work with representative merchant he
has been a strong voice for public
health in the connecticut river valley
and it would be
it would be it would be wonderful to
have his expertise
on the team
the chair recommends to the speaker of
the house that if this bill passes
representative merchant and
the one that we all know is the senator
will be appointed thank you other
questions
i just want more of a comment than a
question are you you making i just want
to say thank you to representative
apprentice it'd be a privilege to work
with you in this commission
my other question i guess is when i
think about how this is being structured
in the world of medicine in a lot of
other professions we always talk about
best practice
and what i would say is in my time in
talking working with a hospital to
pharmacy areas which is my expertise
when we pull people together from 14
different hospitals
we learn from each other
and we learned from that process to
identify the best practice or things
that they were doing that we could take
and try to emulate within our own
organizations
so and i look at this as an opportunity
for people to come together
and at that point in time talk about how
they're doing things and then learn from
each other it's a learning tank if you
will
and at that point in time try to help
develop best practices or best practices
yes
that was a great question
representative folsom
since it seems we're waiting for an
amendment to show up um i'll just put my
two cents in make it a nickel yeah
i would hope or i'm hoping you are
planning
to allow um these regional
[Music]
uh organizations to retain their
regional flavor
um
you know i
my concern is
that
in this attempt to
too much all the same when we have such
different
um
different communities across the state
so my question is are you hoping to
um allow the different flavors uh and
cultures of our different uh counties
and regions to remain
a part of the process
thank you for the question
representative folsom and i think that's
that's key to all of this there are some
things that you know there's like a
floor and there's a ceiling
but when it comes to public you know in
term there's a floor and there's a
ceiling when it comes to public health
and i talked about this a little bit
during my testimony in one part of the
state we might have an you know an issue
with um you know child passenger safety
and we need to address that or you know
or obesity that needs to be addressed
that's you know
come coming forward in higher rates of
you know type 1 and type 2 diabetes you
know there so there's an issue that that
public health
community has said we need to focus some
time and efforts on this because this is
really threatening the well-being that
sounds like a strong word it is you're
gonna it's impacting the well-being of
our community of our communities that we
serve together so let's address this so
there is there should be the room for
that and as it is now
yes but what you know there's not this
is a formal but informal structure that
needs
i believe more of a form formal
recognition i believe that i believe
that you know it needs to be codified
but those are the questions that others
are going to answer and make decisions
about what they want to do so directly
yes
we will not lose the local flavor that
would be the point of it we'll see and
and the rest will be answered by this
seeing no further questions
you wouldn't have brought a question in
from the outside would you have
represented nader no you didn't didn't
go get one all right
thank you senator
well we've got 10 15 minutes and this
would be a wonderful time to execute
except we don't have the amendment yet
this ends the hearing on 419 and i'm
those of you who took one a minute ago
don't have to go again
unless you have to go again
mr chair
uh just a um
a a sign on leeches they uh leeches are
still very much used i said that oh okay
okay it draws circulation as a handgun
we use them in replant
yeah but i want to be sure people
understand that not available to local
pharmacy
not by standing order
you can you can go into a leech
ivermectum twofer if you will they're
very expensive
open the hearing on house bill 337 flown
in at great expense
to speak to us from just over there is
good morning and uh
i
love a good sense of humor
so i
once again thank you for having me
before you again for what is this the
fourth and possibly final time today and
maybe
even this session i think this is it for
me chairperson
you're not senator abard no
i'm not uh mr chair do we have the
amendment
we've moved on to another bill
thank you 337 we're going to go to 337
we are on 3 37 oh i think so yeah is
this quarter of 12 yes yes we are on
3 37 okay
and to answer your question we don't
have that bill the amendment on 419 so
it's
here
okay
so again well we are still in mourning
so good morning again jer pearson and
members of house health and human
services and elderly affairs again for
the record state senator sue prentice
from the beautiful connecticut river
valley
i am here to introduce um senate bill
337 this is legislation that was
requested
by the new hampshire department of
safety to clarify language in both 20
rsa 21 p12 b
and rsa 153 a 35 section 2 regarding
sharing by formal request
again formal request of ems and trauma
data for the purposes of research and
analysis in my time as the chief
of new hampshire's bureau of emergency
medical services at the department of
safety we built and implemented
an electronic data reporting system and
became the second state in the nation
to submit data to the national ems
information data system this was
out in the field first responders public
safety professionals
and at the department of safety quite an
accomplishment
this data maintained is maintained in
new hampshire it's our new hampshire
data and it contains valuable
information on that we can and should be
using to continuously evaluate and
improve our ems and trauma system
without research and analysis
capabilities at the department of safety
opportunities present themselves at the
federal and state level upon request we
can take advantage of this and get this
work done updating the language will
clarify the process will not expand the
data set that we already share and most
importantly uphold the strongest and
strictest of confidentiality standards
all requests for ems data are reviewed
by a privacy committee that's been
established in rsa 153a
and final approval to share
any data um under whether under contract
would be done by
with would be done with the consent of
the commissioner of safety
so i humbly ask for your support for
this senate bill 336 the 337
and i want to thank you for your time
and i'm happy to answer any questions
you might have we do have a
representative from
the department of safety a former
colleague of mine um who's the direct
assistant director at fire standard
training ems jeffrey phillips um and we
actually worked together during the time
when we built the system that we're
talking about now and i just if i may
for a moment um chair members of the
committee we have robust data that's
available to us and again we were we
were early birds in this system we were
doing electronic patient care reporting
with the strictest confidentiality
standards
before some hospitals had moved from
paper to elect electronic systems
it's important for us to be able to to
look at this data and continuously
improve the work that we do our patient
care protocols for how we might be
providing a certain kind of medication
uh are people um in would a certain type
of splinting is that still the best way
to splint
there are all these questions
that
need to get answered and using this data
is how that gets done but we don't have
the internal capabilities to do that
we're honest about it and we're i mean
we can answer some questions but we're
approached
sometimes by groups like an academic
medical center say here in new hampshire
or another state agency that wants to
look at the data to answer a question
and that's going to help them as well as
help us so that's why i bring this
before you today thank you any questions
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question uh
in terms of the
uh as mentioned here the the privacy
committee shall review this is how this
is handled
how would that interface with the
current bills that are going through the
house and the senate relative to the
internal structure
uh to deal with the privacy and handling
of data internally would this privacy
committee be part of that or would the
senate bill that's going through
supersede that or
how would they interface
i don't believe that thank you for the
question um
it's not
to my knowledge they don't interface
this privacy committee came up
uh was put into statute it was actually
after i left the department of safety
but i think that it's really strong work
on their part has a broad constituency
and a structure for reviewing these
requests and making sure that the
privacy is i mean we have the strictest
standards
with the systems that we use but it
makes sure that it's meeting those
standards and that's where the final nod
comes before the commissioner takes it
over
um um privacy committee then follow
under the um purview of
this new structure that's being uh
propounded by senate bill
i forgot the number of
423 uh such that
um and house bill 1662 sorry
um
would would they would that
how how would that flow uh because it's
really important it's important from
several perspective privacy but also i
think one of the
real important parts of house bill 1662
is is to avoid hacking issues
if the if it's structured but i'm
concerned that there would be one
committee
off by itself and then another committee
looking at it differently
give a point of information on that you
may 1662 has only to do with the
department of health and human services
that is an internal policy thing for
dhhs this is department of safety so
there's no interaction between those two
so don't have to i saw you're starting
to look it up
yeah no don't worry 1662 is for dhhs
this is their department of safety they
do not intersperse their inner interplay
representative knurk yes i did have a
question as well and that is okay um the
data that's being shared is it
de-identified
representative acton
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
senator
um i'm on the opiate abatement advisory
commission and we receive information
back from
from emts
regularly on what's going on
on the street level and things rapidly
changing uh like for instance we found
out that that
fentanyl is being mixed with xylazine
which is a horse tranquilizer
and does not respond to narcan
so this type of information coming back
up from the street is vital is this
information that would be covered in
this type of uh
in this situation
thank you for the question uh
representative acton so you're you're
actually already getting data from this
data set and using it within the state
system that's structured so the data
that you're receiving and reviewing is
coming from it's called tempsis the
trauma and emergency medical services
information system so that is
what new hampshire has built for its
reporting structure so when there are
questions about you know routinely you
know how you know how much was narcan
this is how much was narcan used in the
last week that report can be generated
at the state level
based on the input of the ems
professionals throughout the state
during that time period
so it is uh that's already covered okay
seeing no further questions thank you
senator
joe recognizes jeff phillips from the
thank you mr chair and representatives
of the committee
for allowing me to speak today my name
is jeffrey phillips i'm the assistant
director of the division of fire
standards and emergency medical services
which is part of the department of
safety
uh we are in support of this bill and
would like to offer a few comments and
then answer any questions that you may
have
as senator apprentice said before
we house a statewide
ems patient care reporting system so all
emts there's approximately 5700 emts in
the state
report to the department of safety uh
within 24 hours of having patient
contact where the the
depository
for all that information
this data is extremely important to the
continued progression of emergency
medical services uh within the state by
allowing our own stakeholders
to be able to use this data to determine
how we can progress ems in regards to
how do we change patient care protocols
we have two boards that specifically
look at this information the medical
control board which is made up of
medical
doctors emergency physicians
they have ultimate say in regards to how
we provide ems care in the state of new
hampshire as well as the ems
coordinating board who oversees the ems
system in general
currently the law limits our ability to
release this information for research
purposes only
this bill expands the ability to share
data not only for research purposes but
for the analysis of the data as well
most recently during the covet 19
pandemic the division was working with
contracting with a third party vendor
that would allow real-time data
analytics
on covet 19 calls
this was specifically for just the
department of safety it wasn't being
shared with anybody else but it gave us
the ability to use a tool um
that would be more readily available to
analyze the data rather than
pulling all the data doing our own
statistics ourselves
however
through the attorney general's office it
was determined that we didn't have the
ability to share it for analytical
purposes it would have to be for a
research related reason
additionally there are many other
opportunities to partner with other
state federal agencies to enhance the
knowledge understanding and response in
certain areas of ems as the
representatives said
brought up before
we have a partnership and we work
closely with dhhs
on opioid related uh information
unfortunately at this point we have a we
have difficulty sharing that information
because it's not a research related uh
it's more for surveillance in in
analytics
another example is motor vehicle crash
data there's motor vehicle crash data in
the state of new hampshire we would be
able to link that specifically with ems
data
to really identify
specific areas throughout the state and
how things
are transpiring by sharing and linking
ems data with these other sources it
will better equip our state and local
first responding agency to be able to
plan
um and create interventions and evaluate
their own performance measures
i would like to highlight that under
existing law as senator apprentice said
there's a privacy committee which
consists of seven members it includes
the director or his designee four people
from one of the ems
boards that i mentioned before and two
people not affiliated with the
department
at the end of the day that committee
would make only a recommendation to the
commissioner of safety and the
commissioner safety would make the final
determination whether that was an
applicable request or not
in closing i would like to thank senator
apprentice for sponsoring this bill and
all the other sponsors of the bill
and just to reiterate that our ems
system in the state of new hampshire is
a model system especially in the
northeast many other states actually
going back to when senator apprentice
was the chief
model a lot of their ems system based
off of the protocols and the things that
we've done in new hampshire
being able to use our own data for
analytical purposes is
vitally important for the fast response
as we've seen in covid
and the continued progression of our ems
system in the state of new hampshire
that's all i have to say if you have any
questions i'll be more than happy to
it's a trouble when people make good
presentations
this closes the hearing on senate bill
337 and i will now open the executive
session
on the same the chair recognizes
representative acton for a motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to move uh
that we otp
8sb 337.
the chair looks at representative
merchant
second
as a co-sponsor that's right
discussion
seeing no discussion
the motion before us is ought to pass on
senate bill 337
move by representative acton seconded by
representative merchant
way too efficient here so uh okay
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton yes
representative gay
representative dolan yes
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes
representative coholt yes
representative delimus
representative mckay
representative kanerk yes
representative snow yes
wow look at that
representative soloway
microphone and all
representative cannon yes
representative nutter up him
representative shapiro
yeah
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes representative query yes
representative pearson yes
nothing
consent and representative acton writes
now we've got some things we can be
doing but oh
this uh concludes the um exec session on
337.
i would like us to go to lunch and
please be back at quarter
to one
quarter two that's when the big what we
don't do begins anymore 12 45
because we do have some other things
we've got to get done thank you
you can come back anytime
keep those bills and senator keep those
bills coming
a quick a quick uh question if we can
just for the committee yes um we're
going to have to have that conversation
about 416. yes we are did anybody pick
up the amendment so that we can have
that oh it was it was emailed to us but
i know some people prefer a hard copy
and i know that was put together i had
actually asked lucy to get me 281 and
got that a hard copy for 416 right here
okay
you may approach
just remember when you leave you back
straight back three steps then turn
i made uh representative cofoul to
promise he called me
uh recently and said uh when would we be
finished and i told him
24 past three
we're going to be uh opening reopening
the executive session on senate bill 404
on
a supplemental nutrition assistance
program
we've already adopted amendment 1386
uh representative leon was recognized
and uh made a motion to interim study i
call upon representative leon
thank you mr chairman i would like to
withdraw my motion is that acceptable to
the co-sponsor
thank you
now the mr
the
chair is
um
will entertain another motion and the
chair recognizes
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman i would like to
make a motion on sb 404 and i would like
to move ought to pass
do we have a second representative
soloway
otpa i'm sorry otpa yeah
sorry yes otp if you are from canada
no
discussion would you like to speak to
your motion representative kelsey
um i just
this i think this bill is very important
i think this bill just moves us into a
position to allow
um to allow this to happen and i
i just think that you know following up
on what representative mcmahon said
earlier i think it's a very necessary
i'm not sure if this is working
thank you mr chairman i think that it's
an important thing i just still think
that it's already possible but i
appreciate the the change in motion
because i think that reflects the
there's the team
fn
establishing supplemental nutrition
assistance program that's 404
fn as amended by
amendment 1386
now moved by representative kelsey
and seconded by representative soloway
please call the roll
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton
representative gay
representative dolan
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofolt no representative
delemus
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative query yes representative
17 to 4
17 to 4.
okay
we are still waiting on
something to come
over from
ols
and
see what else that's 419.
[Music]
um
yeah
please direct your attention to
house bill 416 this is one that i think
i muffed it was supposed to be
exact last week and
got pushed to the corner and got buried
and because of that and it is
an early bill it has to be looked at
by the house on thursday
if you've read the calendar you will see
it just simply lists it by title and
says go to the floor with no
recommendation
but what we can do and i just spoke with
the clerk again over the lunch hour is
we can discuss it
no voting but we can discuss it
and
perhaps i hope
coalesce around one viewpoint or if not
two different viewpoints and in any of
those cases there can be floor speeches
and floor amendments so we can get our
licks in on this
representative weber
has
crafted an amendment 1438
okay better check the stack to make sure
i think
we're good here here's some more
and make sure that it's all this
representative merchant while you're up
i got three for you right here okay yeah
they're under here
okay i think we still need two more in
the middle here two more in the middle
you have extras
so once you get it take a look at it
this is um representative weber's
amendment
and since representative curry is
replacing her you can explain it in
um
hmm
representative knurk have you s uh i
believe you've chatted with
representative weber in regards to this
actually i didn't but i um
between her email and having just read
through it and
i think we did have some conversation
and also recalling the concerns that
came up i can speak to it
there were a couple of things that
needed to be changed
no
yes i'm sorry page two line one
the current reading is uh starting in
the previous sentence that there would
be a behavioral assessment and a
behavioral intervention plan
what was added was
if clinically indicated
in other words not saying that every
single kid has to have this
but that
if it's clinically indicated then it
would occur
then if you work your way down again on
the bill not the amendment page two
lines six and seven and it gave the
information about who would be doing it
the functional behavioral assessment
conducted by a qualified individual and
so on
and now that
uh goes on to say
instead of a qualified individual at a
fair reimbursement rate and is which may
include a board certified analyst that's
individuals qualified to perform the
assessment which may include but is not
limited to
a board-certified analyst or
psychologist so it basically broadens
slightly
um it doesn't set the reimbursement rate
issue which is a good thing
and it uh
kind of
broadens a little bit who can do it it
was not really
it is you say which may include this
kind of broadens it which may include
certified behavior analyst or
psychologist not just behavior analysts
so that's pretty minor changes but those
were things that came up during the
hearing
senator whitley had
agreed i remember we quickly came up
with some wording she had come up with
some wording handed us to the seahander
to christina and we tried to get the
amendment as quickly as possible but
here we are today
the effective date is also changed 60
days after passage two takes effect
january one twenty twenty four yes i'm
sorry i had that written in red and i
still didn't say it
yes just to push it out and the reason
for that is because of the workforce
issues remember this bill also does
put some money into the idea of uh
sorry no i'm mixing up bills um several
but be considering our workforce issues
and getting this into
place we wanted to give more time before
they were
directed to have to get this underway
because they might not be able to do
with current uh current workforce
capability
representative woods
um just a question i had on my notes and
i didn't see that i had an answer to my
question and i may have discussed it so
if the patient happens to be out of
state
can they do the testing before they
bring them back or to the requirement
that the testing be done before they
return to the state
and i assume that that question was
raised and i don't recall the answer
representative knurk
well remember that in the lines just a
little bit above that you can actually
just look on the amendment on lines um
12 and
12 through 14 that if it cannot be
completed prior to entry into
residential treatment the department
shall ensure that ensure that an
assessment is initiated not completed
but initiated within 30 days because i
think that handles that problem because
always we have to find people we
contract with out of state which may be
very cumbersome and difficult and this
allows us to get the kid in
and do the assessment so they're placed
in the right facility and they have the
right treatment plan
representative shapiro
yes i think the the intent is not about
doing this before we bring people back
or bringing them back to their families
but the intent is to
do this as early as possible so that
less
children will have to actually be placed
in residential settings and certainly an
out-of-state residential savings i also
just want to say
that
i think it's good that the amendment
um broadens who can do this um to tell
you the truth i think
i'm not sure what a
board-certified behavior analyst is
because i don't know what board they're
talking about
i think most people who do this kind of
report
are school psychologists not exclusively
but
representative delemus
i'm wondering on line six of the bill or
page two sorry line six where it says by
a qualified individual at a fair
reimbursement rate
is
excluded from the amendment and i didn't
know whether or not that was even
important
or why that had been originally put into
well
line 14 of the amendment talks about
individuals qualified so i i think
that's qualified individuals
right but the reimbursement rights i see
yeah
may i answer that yes you may i think in
general we try not to get involved in
setting reimbursement rates or mandating
what reimbursement rates should be
because that's usually not our position
particularly in the policy committee
even in commerce we generally try not to
anyone else
[Music]
representative gay
i very much support this bill
i was horrified to find out that uh we
needed to correct this serious omission
about sending kids away without ever
even having assessed
done a thorough assessment that's just a
horror story and one of my constituents
is trying to visit her son who is
now 30 but has behavioral but
i don't know because i've never met him
and of course i'm listening to his
mother uh but i mean the place where he
is is far from her home
and when she goes they'll only let her
visit after she spends two and a half
hours to get there they'll only let her
visit for an hour so and and as i
understand in that in the state of
massachusetts there have been real
efforts to try to improve that
school
so
i'm hoping
my hope is that if we pass this and now
they have to do assessments on all kids
considered maybe we'll build one here in
new hampshire where we have more control
over how the people are treated and how
accessible they are to their families
representative shapiro yeah i just want
to say that like
people are complicated and families are
complicated and the system is
complicated um to take care of children
and it's
imperfect at best and sometimes bad
things happen sometimes
we have great results
with kids getting services and coming
back to their families and doing well
and
i don't think we should think of this as
a solution to the whole
big problem i think this is just this
behavioral analysis and behavioral plan
is one tool and i think it's a good
thing that it be mandated that it be
used um
but i don't think we should think that
this in itself is going to be a solution
to
larger systemic problems um
it's a good thing to do it's a small
let me just ask this if we were to vote
which we aren't
okay
if we were to vote and we aren't
yay we come together again
and if we were would you say
consent i don't know we can get away
well what we do is first of all
pass this along to finance division
three
because they got to look at it next and
say this is our discussion our sense of
the meeting
and a straw poll
then
uh when this is actually coming up on
thursday isn't it
so maybe skip finance um or whatever but
um what
representative weber and the clerk and i
have kind of figured out
is
we would ask one or two people
to
um speak to
this bill and it would be sure as heck
nice to have a democrat and republican
do it to say
that in our committee we had pretty much
consensus can't speak for everybody but
pretty much consensus saw a lot of hands
19 at least and uh we go from there
representative canark we will have to
introduce and move the four amendment
first we will obviously uh and will we
will we speak to the amendment itself or
will we first get the amendment through
and then speak to the bill because of
course we shouldn't be
you know speaking to the bill when we
actually have the amendment as the
motion on the floor
uh representative weber told me she
would be trying to get uh the amendment
into the seat
backs right but we still have to
introduce it it has to be and it still
has to be introduced
and voted out and voted on and she plans
to be there right
so it sounds like we're saying
uh let's get it back and actually
another thing is do you want really two
to speak or one to speak and the other
side to do the pi
do you put well all right one second
here just to make it faster for the
house i was thinking if we all sort of
agree and we don't have a vote obviously
but we
have each side present consistently
maybe that might be good signaling
well i don't care if it takes a while i
didn't make a promise okay that the
house would have joined
324. um who on the republican side who
would
you go ahead
uh thank you mr chairman i i think that
if two people were to speak very quickly
on it we could hopefully just do a voice
vote since there's consensus on it
otherwise i understand the pi issue but
that's true
might not get to a pi that's a good
point but let's try to convince you know
limit ourselves to like two minutes
is there anybody who is thinking of
okay so uh we would like two people to
hop up and briefly
speak to the but
one question
during this discussion we talked about
using this functional behavioral
assessment is a tool to measure when
somebody's ready to come home
my impression was when it started that
the main purpose here is to get a plan
before they go
so we're given some instructions to the
placement about what we expect them to
accomplish
and i want to make sure that that
doesn't just
if we if we say this is the way you
decide when they're ready to come home
that's really not good enough i think
what we really need to do is focus on
that first step making sure we have a
plan when they go
is does anybody
have a problem with that and also to
make sure they're getting to the right
setting for care i mean if you can get
them if you can keep them out of a
residential care facility as betty was
saying
sorry representative gay um
and into the proper
lesser level it'll save money it'll be
better for the kid it's better for the
family so we want to try to
get the appropriate it's like anything
else it's like anything in medicine you
want to have an idea what your diagnosis
is before you develop a treatment plan
well i asked my wife about that and she
said she does that all the time yeah
yeah we kind of mentioned that because
it's not a one-size-fits-all
so who i'm looking for a couple people
who might like to speak
representative shapiro what do you know
about mental health issues huh
studied it a little bit i'll make it
brief
and somebody from
decide
well
ready
okay so representative gay if you and
representative shapiro
could get into the cahoots on um
your speeches so you dovetail nicely i
think that
uh do we need a pi lined up ready to go
i think we're gonna try to go for voice
vote
to be blunt we're gonna have a harder
time convincing some republicans if you
do the pi it's gonna carry more weight
than in three that if i get up and do it
okay erica
leon
what are you what are you two as david
scanlon likes to say when you've won
stop
talking okay good this is very helpful
so there's the amendment we have to
speak to but then once it passes we have
to speak to the bill itself correct we
have to speak to the bill as amended so
again strategically one of the things to
consider
is maybe having represented leon
do the pi and the amendment if you do
the pi on the bill as amended
if we need it that's all
okay representative webber gets the
amendment adopted and you will do the pi
on the amendment excuse me if needed
and then speaking to the bill is
representative shapiro and gay we hope
okay i'm calling this very unofficial
but very helpful thing to a close
uh here he is point of order
yes
is there is there some
way we determine if representative
gay speaks first or i speak first it
would just determine which you know what
i what we say well why don't you do we
just decided once you figure out what
you want because i have to turn this in
so they write the script so rock paper
scissors afterwards let me know okay
well that's that's
childish rock paper and scissors is more
courtly
is that is that rate choice voting no
okay we are getting
even more off track than we're known for
uh open the hearing on senate bill 288
establishing a committee to study the
listing of immunizations for children
thank you mr chair well hi committee how
are you for the record i'm senator kevin
avard
and i am the prime sponsor of this bill
uh
so
uh originally a a host of my
constituents
uh do i did i introduce myself right
yeah i did right yeah i'm just chewing
on the word host i was thinking panoply
but hosting yeah
a host of my constituents
uh had called because they were worried
about the mandates and a whole host of
uh
reasons why they wanted the the original
bill put in
uh they didn't want the schools to
mandate the the vaccines and there was a
mirror bill in the house
very similar so we had a lot of people
that were really concerned
and they called up and they said would
you put in a bill so i agreed to put in
the bill
and in the hearing uh we heard again a
lot of testimony uh in favor uh and
there then there were some that were
opposed and then uh came out that well
you know you can't
restrict the schools you can't require
it in the first place it's hhs
and so there was an amendment that was
brought in and then finally another
amendment which we compromised and i
think what we have right now is just a
study
there's a study
so that
legislators like myself
and and abroad will have a better grasp
on how we're coming to get these
vaccines how they're coming into play
who's responsible for him who's the
decision making on that the whole nine
yards and so we did this in energy a
while back because i had no clue about
energy and i was really
confident that i had no clue about
energy
and
so what we did is we had a study
committee and the study committee
basically talked about how uh you know
we talk about generation we talk about
transmission
and
it educated the chair of the committee
to be fair
and so i put in this bill thinking well
that that it was the schools that
actually mandated these things so what
i'm
this is an educational bill for me and
for a host of other people that that
want to come to grips with all right
what's what's out there because
it has been politicized
we know that the whole idea of vaccines
and so let's get to the truth of the
matter let's let's sit down
let's set back take a deep breath
and find out really
you know what are what's the role of the
government
you are forgiven
so that's a pretty high penance senator
uh so really that's the essence of the
bill and i'm hoping to be the chair of
it and uh
i think if any of you known and have any
history with me on on any committee
i'm fair
and i want to get to the truth of the
matter
and i want to get to the truth i want to
get beyond all the
garbage that's out there uh i want to
know what's what what the what the rules
are of engagement and so let's let's do
would you believe yes i would
i'm under orders to kill this bill
from
for one very important reason
although we have
members of the house
the kinds of folks who are able and
willing to serve on committees
is a lot less than that
and
in any committee that's being
established
out of this group
and indeed now out of some other
committees
the speaker's office
tasks me
with finding the people to serve
and it is an increasingly difficult
thing
so the little side deals i'm working
with numbers of your senatorial
you get me the people
i get them i have them already i got
them lined up are you kidding i got an
inside sauce here i i know that and i
had to say it
so who are they
well
i would if missed if if repres i haven't
talked to uh representative connor but i
would like him on there as well if he's
willing to serve okay i'll appoint him
and
erica well i already got her
um we had you had spoken about
representative cushman but she was
looking at her schedule representative
cofould i think had some interest yeah
so we have it yeah oh call far yeah
and who's the fourth we want a breadth
of um party so oh yeah well i um
[Music]
are you willing to serve
i'm not sure
well you're already written an inc go
ahead soloway represents all thank you
mr chairman hi senator um
how
long a period of time do you expect this
uh it's a it's a study committee so it
has to be over uh this year so uh
yeah december 1 2022
i have a history
of my study committees
they get they get done
and uh
there's a fair hearing
um we get results
i believe your word is
can
right
which is jewish for yes
is it really
i didn't know that
it's it's pigeon hebrew
so we've got leon conner cofault and
soloway there's a breath right there
okay i'm happy okay
any other questions for the senator
representative dolan not for the senator
comment of the chair
okay
in support of what you just said a
little a little while ago
about the speaker
i i'm aware of the fact that we have
several
thousand
committees slash commissions
that haven't haven't even met for two
years
truly noted if i may make a comment you
may make a comment
when i put in my study bills for the
energy we had a lot of resistance from
both sides i like that resistance and i
remember
some of my colleagues on on the other
side of the aisle said i'm not going to
teach him anything
and
that's right but you know what they're
very happy they did
because i'm a good chairman of energy
because of it i got a reward from it an
award the other day
um more power to you sir this will get
done
this will get done it'll get be done in
a time of the fashion
and uh we'll get some results
representative kanark
yes i i had more of a question actually
because although i appreciate the
concept i was wondering um thinking
about how we handle a lot of bills over
this year many of them came in as
coveted 19 bills went out as more
generic bills and this one ref
specifically references how they make
decisions about cobit 19. now more
importantly in the
hearing for 1379 we were instructed that
uh dhhs was not going to do anything
about moving ahead with covert because
they felt there wasn't sufficient
evidence to mandate that in kids and
under 1633 where we put in uh 33 third
no sorry i said that wrong 1633 was that
1379 was the bill that we have that has
to do with how the system works
and uh that goes to oversight
um so the question is do we really need
a study committee
to look at this when we
have now
uh oversight committee needing to vote
with a three-fifths vote so every time a
an immunization would come up it's going
to come before oversight so that's going
to be an ongoing sort of committee to
look at it
now that's not something you would have
known when you filed this but does that
make this perhaps not even necessary to
have a committee no i definitely
disagree i think because there's still
ongoing issues with with
information out there and misinformation
with regard to covet and with regards to
the
the uh
the obligations of the cities and
municipalities in the state and i think
we can clarify uh
you know
the people
if you shut it down
if you shut down the conversation it's
not going to help the people
this this will help the people uh
and it'll help their legislators to have
a clear understanding as to the role
of
of the municipal
the state uh with regards to what this
is because i can tell you right now if
you shut down the conversation it all it
does is it fuels the fire
representative
but my intention though if you'd
appreciate it but would you believe was
not to shut it down but just simply
saying since we now have a mechanism
with the uh health and human health
human over
sorry the oversight committee needing to
look at each one individually
that it would not really shut it down it
already has a venue that would you
believe that that was what i meant not
to shut down but to say that there's
another alternative venue already
existing
um that there might be some truth in
that statement however i think that the
people will uh will will appreciate the
fact that uh we're taking a sober look
at this
instead of oversight i can tell you that
oversight looks at this from the long
perspective this is short
concise
now
and then done so i see them as two
different things with oversight picking
up once this committee sunsets
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um i also think
that our
would it be presumptuous for our
committee to assume that uh 1379 is
definitely going to become law or would
it make more sense for us to have this
study committee point of order i just
found out that went to interim study in
the senate so i have to withdraw the
comment m8 1379 does not exist as a
well that was quick you ask it and it's
done
and
first i have a couple comments senator
first of all i want to commend you for
ensuring that both parties represented
on the commission i think it's healthy
for any commission to actually have any
um it's not a commission it's a study
study committee
number two
it's going to bring up the question
about the um
house bill that was recently
sent to interim study
that that was basically looking at if
you will
vaccines to be added to we had a clause
in there
i think this is a great compromise
because one of the things they heard it
through this committee
was a need for legislative oversight
on what the vaccines are what the
requirements are
and this kind of threads the needle
because it does provide a mechanism
legislatively
to look at this issue and then provide
some sort of guidance for policy making
in the future so would you believe that
i agree with you
i would definitely believe that and i
thank you for your comments and i i
think um really i
if if you know me if you know my i
really like to give the people the
opportunity to know that we're actually
working on their behalf and uh i don't
like to shut down the conversation
because the legislature knows best
one of the things that's
grabbed me through the pandemic
is while there's always certain people
who are just going to believe and act
the way they are no matter what
many other people
like the opportunity to be heard it's a
safety valve even if ultimately the
decision goes differently at least they
feel like they've been heard and i see
this as a vehicle to do that and if i
may mr chair the the fact that uh
it is going to be bipartisan you're
familiar with the phrase iron sharpens
honor
and strong debate uh in
really having some very qualified people
i'm already looking at them that
that
that are very very uh
they're above my pay grade
and i i need to hear it and i need to to
let the people um
here
and and and go through all this
information because there's a ton out
there
and everybody's an expert
so
anyway i see you got your hand up so
representative kanark
yes would you believe that
your commitment to fairness is nicely
demonstrated by the fact that you made
it two members of the senate for the
house representative so it's an even
number which means one party cannot
dominate good sign it's the kind of guy
seeing no pink cards oh my goodness
i mean none are needed hey close the uh
hearing on
288 and while he's still in the room i
open the exact session on the same 288
and the chair looks at representative
cofoult for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move out to pass
on senate bill 288 and somebody from the
what is the yiddish what is the yiddish
seeing none
one of my clerks
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative dolan
representative folsom yes
representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
cofoul yes
representative delimus yes
representative mckay yeah
representative snow
yes
representative conner yes representative
salloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutteruppum
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative query
yes
representative pearson yes
21-0
consent
and representative cofoult if you can
write the blurb please thank you thank
you
and this ends the exact session on 288
and we've got a few minutes before the
next hearing
christina do we have anything come up
you know we may go past 324 if we're not
careful here and i hate that
[Music]
all right so we are in recess for a
chair mr chair we have a couple other
bills we can we can do
is
oh
well you know whenever you can always
give me a call and i can shoot you roll
call vote cheats
so
of course this is our last day and
i'll start doing my job on the last day
see in colorado they had a staff person
in that
in jersey
and they were poor
soldiers
he went in exposed to water
and were diagnosed with flying flu
but at the time
of the cdc
was having its congressional attitude
and
one of the congressmen and a bunch of
you
by the way if anybody in the committee
is bored right now and they owe me a
christina daya did her usual
tremendous best and we now have that
amendment
to 419 so since we have a few minutes
before we can
i opened the executive session on senate
bill 419 the only change
is that the date is november 1st 2023
and not
2022 because as representative soloway
and others wisely pointed out uh this
takes going to take a little bit of time
to um take place
uh so
uh let's see
what do we got here
point of order
did somebody ask for point of order yes
is there a certain sequence we have to
take the amendments in you got to take
this is about the original one that was
good was
poor now i'm sorry
dyslexic
so the amendment is 419
representative woods would you make a
motion on that if i move uh
amendment
uh number one or
two zero two two
uh one six four nine h uh to senate bill
419. and the chair will second it is the
co-sponsor um any discussion on the
amendment
it simply changes it a year out
okay seeing none would the clerk call
the role please
yes i do representative land yes
representative mcmahon yeah
representative acton yes representative
gay yeah representative dolan yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes
representative kobal yes representative
delemus
not here
uh representative snow
yes
representative connerk yes
representative soloway yeah
representative cannon yes representative
nutteruppum
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes representative query yes
representative pearson yes
now we have the bill itself 419 as
amended
do know this comes with the writing i
know
representative nada upham what is your
motion i move that senate bill 419
as amended by the um amendment we just
voted on
do i need to name it no okay uh
ought to pass
second from over here representative
kelsey second sets any further
discussion
the motion before us is senate bill 419
as amended by
2022-1649-h
this otpa motion was moved by
representative nada upham and seconded
by representative kelsey
with the clerk
please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton yes
representative gay yeah representative
dolan yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes
representative cofoul yes
representative delemus
representative mckay
he wasn't president i'm sorry
representative snow yes
representative kenner yes
representative salloway yeah
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative query yes
if i may um so senator apprentice said
she would volunteer to chair it were
there other volunteers that we
identified
during this meeting
thank you
one member of the house of
representatives who has been secured for
us and
do you think i should mention that in
the report
by name or just that just say the rep
the representation from the legislature
has already been secured okay thank you
very much yeah any of these is better
christina would it be possible for
the four people that i've named to the
uh committee of conference
on 503.
um i need some photocopies
and i'll give you the the stuff to be
photocopied
okay
four copies of both of those please
mr
chair mr chair
representative uh yes just uh adding to
the uh 503 there was a third section
that they added as well
and that had to do with
independent uh stu uh ordering lab
studies
they attacked that or attacked that on
as well check to see if what you have is
consistent with what christine is going
to make photocopies
about side by side right
let's see if the amendment includes
yeah she's bringing back the amendments
open the hearing on senate bill 390 an
act relative to telemedicine and
telehealth
the chair recognizes senator abard the
welcome back friends
all right uh thank you mr chair and the
committee members for the record i'm
senator kevin avard i represent district
nashua awards one two and five brookline
greenville hollis mason
new ipswich and rindge and i am the
prime sponsor of sb 390
which attempts to narrowly extend expand
telehealth access to the granite staters
and throughout the last several years we
have seen an acceleration in consumer
demand
and the use of digital health technology
consumers have been and have embraced
telemedicine and have come to expect it
with surrounding states allowing for
technology this legislation is seeking
to enable
this proposal will help new hampshire
keep pace with surrounding states in
utilizing other technology and
modalities sp 390 attempts to take a
precise approach
to allow for the use of asynchronous
technology in situations where where
timely care and convenience are wanted
and in-person care is not
necessary
asynchronous telemedicine can be used
for things like hair loss minus can
rashes rashes etc and so this
legislation doesn't make any changes to
the insurance reimbursement and i
believe that telehealth study commission
is ongoing and has been looking at those
issues
and is uh is the right form for
discussion of any reimbursement changes
during the senate process stakeholders
worked on an amendment that addressed
any concerns that were expressed during
the hearing and the senate amendment
ensured transparency for patients
and made sure that the providers could
determine what type of telemedicine was
appropriate
for their patients and i would um
definitely like to thank representative
knurk for getting an amendment drafted
for today's hearing following the
passage of sb 390 in the senate with
some
technical and grammatical
grammatical errors uh which were
identified so rep kirk
amendment will canark
amendment will ensure i know kirk yeah
yeah
uh
two dapper gentlemen
uh rep canarque amendment will ensure
total clarity uh for the providers using
this telemedicine this bill actually was
confused with another building not too
long ago and um
i've got a ton
of emails and people calling up saying
don't get rid of my telemedicine
and i'm thinking wow i didn't realize
there were so many people that were
technology i just i was really really
surprised especially in the southern
border of new hampshire
there are a lot of people that use
telemedicine
and one of the benefits i think that
you'll see is that you know we're all
talking about mental health and how that
there's a crisis and this is one way to
expand uh some services for for that
that area so and i i'm sure uh
representative kaner can talk a little
bit more about things of that nature but
it's it's really a simple fix and it's
it's narrow in scope and so we hope that
senator your testimony that you read
from would you have a copy that we could
have yes thank you i plan on moving the
and by the way i am dyslexic
well we have to use other parts of our
brain
we listen we listen
so
thank you i know you happen to believe
in dog
yay verily i believe in god yeah
representative natarapam
would you believe
when i had my endocrinology appointment
sometime this winter by telemedicine
that my provider said because of
telemedicine her elderly diabetic
patients who usually drop off and don't
come for appointments during the winter
because of transportation difficulties
were
almost 100 percent there via
telemedicine so i'm a great proponent of
telemedicine and um for a lot of
people with disabilities people with
transportation troubles it just make or
time
constraints it makes great sense would
you believe
i believe and thank you for voting for
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you senator for being
with us this afternoon uh would you
believe that some of the cardiac devices
as well are able to keep the doctors
appraised and even smart scales to check
when people are swelling and to catch
them ahead and would you believe that i
think this is a great bill that will
help get that access to our people i
think we've all already established that
i'm a believer
all right thank you any more um
questions for the senator
seeing none the chair recognizes our
very own representative jerry kanerk who
who has handout amendments
bye
okay so for the record jerry carroll
county district 3.
um
so yeah i'm a co-sponsor on this bill um
i was contacted
regarding on behalf of a couple of the
telehealth platforms that they had some
concerns about some language
but just linguistically it's kind of
interesting if you can pull the bill out
and look at lines 16-17
remember when you have a series it's
always good to be able to drop
to isolate any one word and see if it
makes sense so nothing in this section
shall limit a provider's ability to
or the provider's ability to
consultation
you know so just grammatically it was
poorly written but the issue is
allowing the word assess so if you pull
out now the amendment so again bill
page 1 line 16.
amendment
is on line 5.
it changes it to diagnose assess or
treat things let's say you have
something
you're just doing rhythms and it's a
monitoring and the person can then the
cardiologist can look at that rhythm
strip and do an assessment they're not
doing a diagnosis you already got a
diagnosis you're not doing a treatment
but they are doing an assessment
so the limitation there of
determine the diagnosis consultation or
treatment besides being grammatically
bizarre
was too limiting and this by the way is
the
uh is a new paragraph that is why it is
not bolded
so it is not currently in statute so i'm
not changing what's in statute because
it is a new paragraph already even
though it is not bold
so that just cleans up that linguistic
mess and also makes it a little more
consistent what we're really doing with
asynchronous uh
telehealth and by the way the cons the
comment that was made about i might
remember about telemedicine
unfortunately i retired in 2015
and we didn't have a telemedicine back
then i made i used to spend two to three
hours every night on telephone calls to
patients but it was not called
telemedicine it was called a telephone
call and there was no compensation other
than that uh we also then go to on the
bill line uh sorry page one
line twenty
eight and twenty nine a health care
practitioner shall complete a history
the bold is the new language
shall complete a shall complete
but in any case they don't always have
to complete a history
they may for example have a patient who
does an online history
filling out a form or from a from a con
they're doing a consultation and so
their primary doc has provided a history
and so instead the languages change too
shall complete or review a history that
allows them to be able to not
necessarily have to take every word
verbatim but they can review it though
anybody
those of us who are practitioners know
that you don't trust somebody's history
they may review it but they sure
certainly should spend time confirming
that the facts are correct
that appears in a second place in the
bill
on page two on line 17
so it is corrected in the amendment on
page two
on line five where once again instead of
just complete a history it becomes
complete or review a history
so this amendment doesn't change
anything in the standpoint of from the
standpoint of the bill substantively it
corrects poor grammar and it also allows
or enables the asynchronous issue for
assessment and the ability of a provider
to review a history that has been
previously provided rather than have to
start from scratch
so that's um and i've run this by rep
senator avard he is happy with it we
have no problems uh he had no problems
with it i should say and it will it'll
make it easier for the telehealth
platforms to actually and um carry out
the intention of this bill
i like it when there's a lot of thought
put into something i i'm not so happy
with things that are jerry built
would you take questions of course i'll
take a question of course you will who
it's for my side
[Laughter]
we tend to be harder on our own i know
yes right representative shapiro thank
you mr chairman i should have really um
asked this of senator avard but i was um
i was too embarrassed to say that i
didn't really understand what this bill
was doing so but i'll
took me a little time to get used to
that so it's the only thing that i
understand there's a lot of grammar
being changed a lot of wording
and definitions but it's the only
practical change that we're doing here
with this bill is adding
a synchronous
um
telehealth
to what already exists in statute um
the
okay well i may i'm hopefully not
skating on two thin ice here but the
other issue is on lines in the bill page
one lines 20 through 25 or so it talks
about developing the practitioner
patient relationship
and it talks about the original statute
talks about uh face-to-face two-way
real-time so that does enable i'm sorry
i'm mixing up slightly with 503 which
had the face-to-face for the first visit
my apology i just realized we have two
telemedicine and i've spent an hour last
night at about 11 o'clock trying to
understand 503. so i was mixing that up
slightly i think
that is the major issue but it um it
allows that asynchronous issue
um and was there one other issue about
this
no that's that's the problem
practically speaking that's the
expansion that this allows for
that is my best understanding of the
thank you
any further questions for the
representative
i'm just checking that i don't have
yes yeah i think that is all that we can
say that it actually does my apologies
chair recognizes kyle zebly and kyle
baker
thank you so much uh chair vice chair
and members of the committee it's real
honor for me to be able to speak uh
before you today my name is kyle zebly i
am vice president of public policy for
the american telemedicine association
and i'm also executive director of ata
action which is our affiliated trade and
advocacy organization and here very much
in very strong support of sp 390. we
think it's a real commonsensical
expansion of access to care for new
hampshire
it would really make sure that new
hampshire is in line with many other
states and pursuing a tech neutral
approach in allowing for providers to
make the determination for themselves
and for their patients whether or not
the standard of care can be met uh in in
terms of interaction with the patient
via the modality of their choice and in
this instance of course asynchronously
we think that obviously telehealth has
been a game changer for
citizens and patients across the country
including in new hampshire and that this
would really again bring new hampshire
up to to speed where many other states
are in allowing for these modalities to
be utilized
as had been noted previously in the
answer to the representatives questions
uh this is a pretty simple
uh
bill that would allow for asynchronous
to be used as a modality and would also
allow for a patient-provider
relationship to be established
asynchronously and i will say that's
very much in keeping with best practices
uh and certainly something that in
addition to the american telemedicine
association endorsing it's a concept
that's endorsed by uh by the american
medical association the federation of
state medical boards and many other
health care professional organizations
so uh again very very supportive and
happy to answer any questions that i can
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and once again i'm
not sure i'm
i'm addressing this to the right person
but in our earlier
telehealth bill
that followed on the emergency orders
which i think was maybe a couple of
years ago
where there was a major expansion of
telehealth
it included parity with in-person
um
with in-person services
so i don't know if there's really a
parallel here with asynchronous
with asynchronous
telehealth
i don't know what the parallel would be
to be doing that in the office
but
is it your idea that that that parity
element which would be included for
asynchronous services as well
thank you so much for the question
representative uh this bill does not
affect uh the issues of the emergency
orders and is not uh concerning issues
of parity uh i believe uh that that is
being studied now as to how the state's
going to determine to cover those
services moving forward both in terms of
of insurance coverage and also insurance
reimbursement but this bill is silent on
that question does that answer your
question sir
follow up follow up
well parity is already built into the
statute for telehealth and
in-person services but
but this would not expand that part of
what's already in statute that's correct
and i just want to introduce myself my
name is kyle baker i work with wrath
young and pignatelli uh in town here and
i represent hims and hers health which
is one of the online
platforms offering telehealth services
um we're the ones who originally came to
senator avard and asked for the piece of
legislation um to be introduced so happy
to answer any technical questions on the
legislation or
sort of how we worked through the senate
amendment process and got to the
seeing no
further questions
thank you kyle and kyle
thank you and we'll have written
testimony for your your review as well
all right everybody on your best
behavior from the new hampshire
microphone
and glasses
we're good
i've never met a microphone i didn't
love so thank you for the reminder
i will be brief today i am paula mattis
i'm the director of medical forensic
services for the new hampshire
department of corrections and i'm
representing that agency this afternoon
thank you for allowing me to speak in
short we are support in support of this
bill for all the points made especially
by representative kanerk and senator
avar
in addition i'd like to add for the
committee's consideration
uh a few items that are of particular
interest to the new hampshire department
of corrections
they are efficiency of services delivery
of services i should say community
safety
and also the
delivery of services
to residents or inmates as dictated by
the eighth amendment of the united
states constitution so
telehealth allows us to
reduce the number of medical runs which
in our field means we don't have to take
residents outside of facilities to go
into community
offices for treatment or assessment
diagnosis etc so by allowing telehealth
services to expand we would be able to
use those more
and we would be able to save money
because we wouldn't be allocating as
many resources to take people out we
would be more efficient because the
exchange of information becomes a little
quicker when you're not waiting for
reports etc etc and finally we would
also be enhancing community safety
because any time we take someone outside
of a prison into the community you are
increasing the chances of escape or
other violent actions resulting in that
community presence so we are very much
in favor of this bill and
respectfully requesting the committee to
support it
again i have submitted written testimony
i can answer any questions now or you
can reach me after the hearing if there
is additional information i can provide
again thank you so much for letting me
speak today
any questions
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here um i i'm looking at your
testimony and you talk about expanded
opportunities to partner with community
practitioners for areas like medication
assisted treatment does this bill do
what you need to do or is it just part
of the effort in order to get mat to
these inmates it is just part of the
effort we have a comp a robust i shall
say robust mat program and we are
looking at changing our model a bit to
become also an moud program which is um
allow
this isn't the place for that but i'm
happy to answer that later but um having
mat allows us to access other
consultants that not mat telehealth
allow it would allow us to uh have
access to other consultants and in
different places if we should need them
for a particular patient thank you thank
any further
questions i know what an msw is
national social worker yes work but what
is a fosse
f.a.c.a i love that pronunciation
it is a um an acronym that stands for
fellow in the academy
of um
certified health care executives
ah well
totally jolly good yes fellow
thank you so much welcome any other
questions
yes representative nutter upper my i
need a few more minutes to get her into
my phone oh thank you for allowing my
question thank you for taking my
question of course i've lost my manners
sometimes
um i just want the answer
moud what does that is medication for
opioid use disorders of course okay
perfect thank you thank you for asking
and then you have
private rooms within the
facilities that the patient can
telehealth with
oh yes i mean can you describe that just
for a second well it varies by facility
because all of our facilities were built
at different times with different
designs but it's simply we would use an
exam room in our health services center
and in each of the prisons has a health
services that's correct the prisons do
and the secure psychiatric unit does and
then for people at our transitional work
center there's an office there or we
would bring them back to the prison and
find a room there to conduct this
service okay thank you very much thank
you
thank you so much okay thank you
close the hearing on senate bill 390 and
open the exact session on the same
and the chair would like to recognize
representative canuck for a motion
so i would like to move amendment number
one five eight nine to a two uh senate
and the chair is happy to second that
the question before us
amendment to senate bill 390
made move by representative canaric rep
seconded by the chair and with the clerk
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yeah
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative dolan yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
absent
representative king yes
representative cole fault yes
representative delemus
representative mckay yeah representative
snow yes representative kenner
yes
representative salloway yeah
representative cannon yes representative
nutter
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes
representative query yes representative
pearson yes
the chair no not an amendment
it's all right but nice try
i know it's exciting isn't it
uh chair calls on himself to make a
motion and my motion is ought to pass as
the motion before us is senate bill 390
as amended by amendment 2022-1589
moved by the chair and seconded by
representative canark
representative land yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative dolan yes representative
folsom yes
representative king yes
representative kofol yes representative
delemus
representative mckay yeah representative
snow yes representative connerk
yes
representative salloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes
representative query yes representative
pearson
yes
20 to nothing 20 to nothing
consent
yes and i'll write the blurb
this
includes the exact session on senate
bill 390. now
is there anything we haven't done that
i'm not aware of
otherwise they'll be in a lot of trouble
when we all come back next week
no but i want to make a quick comment to
the chair
and to the committee
when i looked at our
list today every single one of them came
with i think
all of them all of them all the ones on
the hearing yes
404 which was snap but that wasn't on
our list but today ah
yes representative
yes we do have one other order of
business though before you dismiss this
and that is we have to give you some
advice or advice and consent on hb 503
that was
one of the things you said we needed to
talk about because we have to decide
whether we wish to accede to the senate
or not
and i'd be glad to speak to that if you
wish me to do so the chair has actually
made an executive decision that we will
be having a committee of conference i
get to make that call
i can be advised by people
why
because
[Music]
it didn't look like it sufficiently
matched what we did
and he says backpedaling
um i could be persuaded otherwise may i
try you give it your best shot here's
the scoop um you know this went over as
a housing stability bill and they did
make a few changes on the uh text of
what we sent them which you know there
was a there was a non-germane amendment
which of course the senate is famous for
there are a few things that they changed
i mean they for example did some issues
in the
adding bureau of housing supports
department of health and human services
to make it clear what department we're
talking about those are pretty minor
issues about who uh appoints the
representatives of the philanthropic
community and so on all those are pretty
minor changes i think what got people a
little bit
uh give some heartburn to people was the
massive change in the telehealth part
that was a whole new section of the bill
that was not part of the bill to begin
with that was the non-german amendment
as i said my eyes were crossing over to
about 11 o'clock last night as i was
trying to understand all this and to
give some historical pictures for those
who were not on this group a couple of
years ago
back in 2020 we passed 1623
uh house bill 1623 now what that bill
did actually let's just look at the big
picture we have seen an expansion of
telehealth which began before covet as
we were beginning to realize things we
could do that might make sense
and starting with the work that jay khan
did this bill 1623 was
introduced by brett marsh
and we were starting to expand things
and of course again this was done in the
2020 session it was uh before covet hit
and then with covid we did a lot and we
saw the benefit
of working uh with telemedicine to any
number of situations and we realized
that those benefits persist so after the
state of emergency we're still trying to
kind of clean up and figure out how to
make things work better what this
particular bill was it came in with a
rather narrow focus and has expanded a
bit
to allow
the uh the um
that there would not need to be a
face-to-face
uh
a service provided um
sorry i'm not saying this well in
certain key situations of being treated
for opioid use disorder by
medication-assisted treatment that you
would not have to have a pre-existing
face-to-face relationship with the
patient
and the uh this was going to be through
the va
if you're in a correctional facility as
we just heard from paula mattis if the
patient is being treated in one of the
doorways if they're in a mental health
center or in a hospital those were the
amended version of 1623
set those as
exceptions to needing a face to face
before
and the reason for that is that people
with opioid use disorder when they kind
of realize that they need some help
there's a narrow window
if you talk about the doorway program
there's a narrow window for them to jump
in and get their help
and they're these are some of our harm
reduction work that we're working on now
what was uh if you did see though it
came from um jim monahan he sent an
email and then he sent a mail a mailing
hard copy to all of us so i think it
arrived on the weekend or something like
that
the issue is that we found that there
was a massive increase in people having
accessibility to uh medication-assisted
treatment
with telehealth
and
the idea was since that worked so well
for people who were not
in the hospital mental health setting
correctional facility you know or the
doorways program it worked well for
people that are just in the community
they could come in
access
uh in a very narrow window
opioid use disorder management
medication management and there there
was a very nice
couple of graphics that they sent
regarding the time
during covid often within less than an
hour 77 of people were linked in for
treatment
pre-covered that was two percent
postcode is still still only 12 because
now we put up a barrier because they
have to have this face to face
by the time they're going to get into a
face-to-face they may have changed their
mind
they may have decided they're not going
to go ahead
with
approaching medication-assisted
treatment
so what this bill what they what the
senate did was remove
basically i view it as not something
that's contradictory to 1623 but it's
moving on
from what 1623 started
saying hey
this really worked better we've learned
a lesson so why don't we go ahead and
just let this happen
so what they're doing if you look in
there on the side by side that christina
dyer so nicely provided for us several
pages in
you'll see a lot of strikeouts
and those strikeouts are all that those
five things that representative marsh
put in at that time back in 2020 of
restricting it to being in the
va a correctional facility doorway
mental health facility or a hospital now
it's just you can establish it
and get going
so it allows the patient to access
medication and sit this their assisted
therapy in a timely fashion it does it
exempts methadone because that's a
little bit more complex and it's a
long-term treatment very well long-term
and different
um
we're basically talking suboxone and
those things such as well she's not here
anymore but such as paul mattis i almost
wish she were because it'd been fun to
hear what she would say although she was
already able to do this to the
correctional facilities but this allows
the general public who is not
incarcerated or hospitalized or in a
doorways
to access medication assisted treatment
in a timely fashion
which is an enormously important harms
reduction maneuver to prevent overdose
and get people on the right road to
recover because we start them on
medication assisted treatment one of the
goals is this is the idea of the
doorways is also get them started to be
treated on other aspects of mental
health issues and so on that need to be
addressed
to help get them away from their
substance abuse that they started to
begin with
so i view this that's why i'm looking
this with a perspective and i've been
here long enough not as long as
representing mcmahon but i've been here
long enough to have a little bit of that
time perspective i just had to get that
one in um of looking at how things have
evolved over time
as i said when i gave my testimony on
when i was in practice we didn't have
telemedicine i finished i finished only
seven years ago
duh now it's become quite popular not
just popular but effective and efficient
and this is a way for us to make a
difference in our opioid
epidemic that we're still trying to
treat we still have a lot of overdoses
if we can get people in and get them
treated we're going to do them a huge
favor
so
i don't see any reason to have a
committee of conference to disagree with
with this because again though it looks
really imposing when you have a
multi-page side by side
a lot of this because it had to modify
the nurse practice act the physician
practice act all that so it's all that
redundant language like you frequently
see when it has to do different
providers but it's all the same language
and i think it's a very positive step
toward moving telehealth
into the 21st century um
so i i would favor just proceeding to
the senate's position on this
while i
while i completely agree with um
representative canark's um
view that we should
enhance what we already have in terms of
expand this a little bit more to people
in their homes who are not in
institutions and and and by the way that
also kind of aligns with the mobile
crisis system that um this will be
available for people
um to be initiated during a crisis when
mobile crisis teams go to people's homes
i don't know how often that would happen
but it would be in a line with that kind
even though i totally agree with him
from our earlier conversation i'm a
little confused about
which
amendment was added to which bill was it
a telehealth bill first or was it a
housing stability bill first and
that seems to be the
issue that the two of these got joined
representative canarch it was a housing
stability bill first i actually believe
it or not was able to find it i was
surprised that i was able to find this
from last year and even more surprised
what i found 1623 from two years ago but
it we we were faced
we all we did this one i think on zoom
back you know last year
with uh this bill it came in as a bill
for the new hampshire commission on
homelessness there were questions about
it was it redundant with the council on
housing stability that the governor had
put in by administrative action what
happened but it really wasn't because
the housing stability had more to do
with workforce housing this had more to
do with homelessness it was a co
this uh commission was a coalition of a
number of different organizations to
work on the issue of homelessness that
was the original bill that is 503. the
senate in their usual fashion of
attaching non-jermaine amendments
record you know basically people came to
them saying we need to address this
telehealth issue and of course it's
after the bill filing time
um when the
emergency
you know declarations are over and stuff
and they suddenly saw the spike in
people not getting access and so they
went to the senators i'm not sure who
brought in for this amendment and asked
them to place this in as a non-germain
amendment
and it was placed as a non-german
amendment so the homelessness was the
original thrust this totally non-germane
adds the telemedicine
uh
face-to-face redefinition was it
retained
yes that's why it's that's why we're
seeing it such a long way out it was the
senate calls it a different thing they
called it re-referred to committee
that's how they handled it when it came
to the floor in the senate because they
wanted to look at it some more and they
wanted to kind of change some of the
population
um then when it went into um
when they worked out this year which i
don't know why they waited to send this
to us this late but they finally got
around to
working on it and putting their
non-german amendment in and then we
thank you mr chairman um
this non-german amendment
is
i the only term i can use is
non-diplomatic
um
there's going to be a yiddish phrase for
that no it is it is really certain
saying to the spine surgeon
doc while you're in there fusing my
vertebrae can you fix my bunions
we have no expertise on this committee
on housing stability we shouldn't be
asked to vote on it it's inappropriate
for the senate to provide this non j and
actually as representative knurk has
given us the history of it the darndest
part i would have said damnedest but i
know i'm in good company the darndest
part of it is that we
are the non-germane amendment because it
was originally a housing stability bill
this is
there is the yiddish word i can't use it
may i respond to that please yeah but
well actually with all due respect
it was initially
a commission on homeless it did come to
our committee we passed it out of our
committee 19 to 2.
um and when i was referring to 1623 that
was giving you an historical perspective
of the telemedicine piece but the bill
itself the base bill was a bill we heard
and worked on in the 2021 session we
sent it out of our committee ought to
pass with an amendment 19 to 2 but then
went through the house i don't remember
it passed well whatever it doesn't
matter and then it went to the senate
the non-german part is the telemedicine
again as i say i think
although i was not privy to this at the
time
the i think what probably happened is
they saw the explosion of poor access
and then they went to among the senators
and said could you stick it on a bill
which they do all the time you know
we've got a reputation for being such a
darn good committee that's why everybody
wants to send things to us now we got to
do worse next time
so i mean they're really it really is
totally separate but they have not
they really haven't changed the
commission on homelessness very much
that's still there in the first portion
of the bill but what they've done is
they've added all this other stuff and
it is a pain in the butt for us to have
to deal with it but it is what we get
when the senate sends non-jermaine
amendments back to us
he did it
i did it without my teammate did you use
that
could i request that uh
jim monahan from the duplog group come
up i asked him a question about this
before he had a very good explanation so
if we could let him explain why about
the issue of germaine versus
non-germaine
sure okay thank you very much and i
appreciate you all taking a hard look at
this this afternoon um representative
kenick really summarized it uh very well
but um
uh as the data you can see that was
included in the packet um after the
emergency order was lifted it really
jumped off the page that people were
following or not being able to get
access to care
we worked with a department initially to
see if we could resolve it through
administrative rules this was in october
and weren't able to do it so we did
approach the senate
um and in their defense i wouldn't say
they stuck it on it we thought we they
we actually uh went through the same
process that the house would have
required uh the bill was it and the
senate health and human services
committee had been referred uh we had a
publicly noticed public hearing
we arranged for people to come in and
testify on it we
got the support of dr ballad
the medical director of state
department of health and human services
and the addiction community felt that
something needed to be done
it was after the deadline so we weren't
able to file it as a normal piece of
legislation and frankly hope that it
would move along a little quicker
actually the senate acted on the bill in
january
um and
i don't know why it took so long to to
for the the clerk or the speaker to kind
of push the health and human services
but you also i also know you had a lot
of work with all your house bills and
all your senate bills and so that's why
it would appear to be uh toward uh the
last minute but i did want to make sure
that the committee was aware that uh uh
well first of all blame me
uh for for the process but we did make
sure that we had a public hearing on it
and gain uh support for it and in the
process of that we also did a
presentation uh to the
telecommunication the telehealth
oversight committee uh and they sent a
letter to the senate endorsing the
amendment
if you were me
and if that took place you'd take a
whole horrific pay cut
um
you would concur with the senate's
version of this
yes i would and i and that was the
reason that i've been bearing you in
mail and emails about that
uh is to seek a concurrence i think it
at least i don't want to be unfair to
the committee but we did our best to
make sure that there was consensus in
the
uh in at the department health and human
services the telehealth uh
medical society all the bases we touched
all the bases but we haven't got
to home plate yet and i guess that's
here
representative canark yeah just a quick
thing just for everybody the hearing i
just hadn't dug it up quickly enough the
hearing in the senate was on october
26th after the bill filing time uh by
the time they did it they did pass it
out uh
at a voice vote on january 5. again i
have no idea of why the senate
sat on it or who sat on it for all that
time but in any case um they were quite
satisfied with it and i think that we
should be comfortable with it
yeah i think the docket if you have it
there representative conrad it's it's
it's still the last entry is senate you
know so
um
you do you do realize that if um
i admit you probably convinced me then i
will have to fire representatives acton
mcmahon woods and shapiro from a
committee of conference
they may not want that they'll probably
be happy
okay anybody else on this obviously i
didn't do my homework on it i didn't
want to but thank you that you did as i
said i i started working on it before
and then i realized last night
particularly with lucy not here
that somebody needed to really do all
this work and so i was up until forever
last night
looking at this till my eyes were
crossed but i think i finally made sense
out of it so
okay this is helpful i'll walk over to
i i don't have any
problems signing off on the telehealth
part that we're we're adding i just have
no idea what we're adding with the other
part um is that
is that um
something that we've approved in the
past or is it something is it the same
thing we approved in the past is it
something we want to approve of now yes
um
yeah we we as i said we passed this bill
it was hard it's hard to remember
because it was last year and there's but
that's unchanged
nearly that's that's right let me go
over a couple of the changes if you pull
out the side by side uh which is
extremely helpful on this
um and we look at the membership
it talks about how many vacancies will
be handled
the changes were trivial for example two
individuals one who would be a young
adult with recent experience housing and
stability the changes quote okama
appointed by the governor
because it was left out by us as to who
made that appointment and normally it's
nice to know who makes the appointment
if we look in the bureau chief of
housing supports and behavioral health
supports
and children of youth and families it
adds comma department of health and
human services and that identifies who's
going to make
the appointment
and then there's
two representatives of local providers
of housing services
comma appointed by the governor
that's not exactly a big substantive
change and then there's one new thing a
representative of regional planning
council appointed by the council
that's perfectly reasonable we all have
regional planning councils and they help
to figure out these issues like for my
areas lakes regional planning council
and then if you look in the
philanthropic community in the business
community both those are a comma
appointed by the governor that's all
that's added
and then for law enforcement it makes it
clear if you get represented for law
enforcement who's going to do it
comma appointed by the new hampshire
chiefs of police association
and then nami
is uh
put in i think nami was not there but
now they're added because after all many
people with housing problems have mental
health problems and there's only one
other thing they added in the charge
develop a comprehensive state plan on
homelessness
um
then it has some issues about you know
who calls the meeting and when the
reports are due and that's it so it is
fundamentally precisely the bill that we
passed out of this committee 19 to 2
back in the
spring of 2021
and here's the bill except for this
these few changes identifying who's
going to make the appointments and that
kind of stuff so it is a let's get the
phrase right here a minor cleaning up of
things a housekeeping bill is the chair
may call it but no
no seriously they just clarified because
we left it undefined as to who makes the
appointments and normally in commissions
you define who makes the appointment
so
it is something we have seen it is
something we took a position on 19 to 2.
yeah
i you know sorry as i said it took me a
long time last night of finding all the
stuff and getting it organized to be
able to figure out what the heck went on
all right as the secretary of state says
when you've won stop talking
representative woods
just for my own clarification um
the side by side includes this business
about the
individual being able to test
independently but
we have the amendment
from last fall and i'm not sure what is
actually in play here
uh at this juncture
um because the amendment uh from our
committee on house bill 503
as of uh last october does not include
that
but the side by side did
does that mean the senate added
on pay on page um
i thought there were pages yeah there's
no pages on it which makes it a little
difficult uh on the last
full page
um
uh it talks about uh the bill authorizes
the laboratory testing without a
um it's nice
the same from numbers
my apologies
stapled things like i i think i have
enough to make my decision and
the chair wishes to apologize to
representative cofoult i promised would
be out of here by 3 20 something and
it's not going to happen
we're getting close
may i ask what your decision is sir
i'll concur yay thank you welcome you
owe me
all right everybody
uh missed
i could
we had also um which
of the woods was
speaking to is on house bill 381 which
the amendment
uh the house sorry the house version was
amended by the senate was that approved
by us
did you concur with this one
we talked about that i have concurred
with 381 and uh 1390 already yeah okay
thank you yeah we did that we will be
getting some more
uh the clerk of the house told me
and uh what i'll do is the obvious ones
i'll just make my decision and the ones
that require some serious pondering i'll
shoot out to you guys and look for your
considered opinions
give me shoot out by email
yeah yeah any sort of
quietly or we could do telehealth yeah
okay
did we get everything done yeah
actually may i ask i don't we don't have
any more business than currently
scheduled unless something bizarre comes
up correct
yahoo thank you
is anyone not coming back we say goodbye
to
well i probably won't get reelected but
other than that
uh there's likely to be something in in
september where we have to come back yes
we'll have routine so before the next
study we'll have and we'll have to have
no we just have to do that mr chairman
are we going to have an opportunity for
it's kind of late it's already three
o'clock
um
don't
wow
um
and
thursday
i'm not going to talk
well you know the problem is we're
bringing
i try to organize them all in order that
you